[Music]
foreign
thank you
this is NHS crisis your say I'm Sarah J
Meade with a special program here on Sky
News this afternoon getting your views
on the state of the Health Service
Hospital waiting times are the longest
in history with thousands of surgeries
canceled as a Health Service struggles
to cope
ambula's response times are the slowest
on record and crews are spending entire
shifts parked outside hospitals waiting
to offload their patients
a poll suggests a third of people are
unable to book a GP appointment and the
111 phone service is facing
unprecedented demand
foreign
with the NHS on its knees industrial
action is spreading in a deepening
dispute with the government do you
support the Striking workers or
completely disagree with their action
and if you have a positive story to
share we want to hear it whether you
work within the NHS or you simply want
to praise the treatment you've received
we want to hear from you this afternoon
to have you all say you can call us
0208-167-2200 and you could be on air
with us this afternoon
foreign
[Music]
this is NHS crisis your say today Sky
News is launching a year-long project
with analysis from two leading think
tanks to find solutions to this crisis
that is gripping our National Health
Service and this afternoon we are taking
your calls we want to hear from you it's
a real chance to share your views about
what is happening to the Health Service
before we get into your calls plenty of
you lining up to speak to us I just want
to introduce you to Our Guest that will
be with us for the duration of the
afternoon we have Roy Lily with us
policy Health policy analyst and former
Vice chairman of West Surrey and North
East Hampshire health authority
alongside Roy this afternoon Dr Ellie
Cannon GP and author welcome to you both
um don't forget the number to call today
if you want to speak to us here in the
studio 0208 167 double two double over
there'll be plenty of reminders of that
number on the screen throughout the
program for you here on Sky News today
right let's hear from you first on the
line today we have Victoria from Horsham
we're going to be talking in this
section about waiting times in the
Health Service and the experience you
have if you are able to see one if
you're able to get access to treatment
Victoria and West Sussex
um his father died in hospital
um after waiting five months to be
discharged and Victoria thank you so
much for calling in to speak to us here
this afternoon and no talk to me about
what happened to your dad
um initially it was about 7th of August
um I sort of went to his flat and found
him in a bit of a state so I called 999
and they were there literally within
half an hour so you know that was a
great positive
um they looked after him they took him
to hospital and he had some gastric
stomach gastric infection that was
causing him to be quite poorly
um so they kind of gave him antibiotics
and fluids and that was all okay and
then I was told you know your dad can go
home but he was quite frail so he
wouldn't need some sort of care package
to go home with
um and that never came and this went on
and on and then he kind of got covered a
couple of times he'd never had it before
he's always been really careful so that
was disappointing
um and then he got over that and again
was ready to go home again and then
again no care package and then just
before New Year's
um he got like a proper flu so he was
isolated into a sort of separate room we
could still go and visit
um we did sort of usual PP and
everything
um and then the flu uh went to his chest
he got a chest infection and sort of the
first week of Jan he developed pneumonia
and he passed away on the 6th of Jan
through pneumonia
oh Victoria first of all I'm so sorry
for your loss
um but just listening to all of that
your father was waiting for five months
yeah to be discharged from hospital we
originally went in with stomach problems
correct and then he he died in hospital
from unrelated Matters from absolutely
yeah from what you've been saying yeah
um talk to me about how that happened
you mentioned a care package and that
wasn't able to be put in place now I
know what a lot of people may say to you
Victoria just of curiosity you know your
father clearly had family had you he may
have had other members of family and why
couldn't he go home what kind of care
did he need and it wasn't being given by
the NHS that made him stay in hospital
for five months he needed very sort of
intimate Personal Care
um so he'd lost control of his bowel
after having this gastric infection so
he was wearing sort of incontinence part
of like almost like nappies really
um and he also
um had got very frail he was had a lot
of muscle wastage while he was in
hospital
um he was having some kidney problems as
well
um he was kind of waiting to see his
kidney doctor all this time so that were
desperate to get him home so there were
other symptoms he was quite anemic
there's other problems but just just
things that you know I know she's got
specific medical training
um it's not something that just a family
member could pick up and he needed to
sort of care with everything you know
getting up his personal care washing
um where he lived wasn't really suitable
so that was another thing but they
couldn't get him moved somewhere more
suitable until he was home and then he
could be assessed so everything was kind
of pinned on him getting home with the
care package and he then would have been
moved um to a they call it like an extra
care scheme where they have nurses on
site that live there they have walk-in
wet rooms so his bathing would have been
easy he could have done that himself or
where he lived he would have needed help
with pretty much everything
um I worked full-time I've got two
children so unfortunately I wasn't able
to you know give give up work to kind of
give them that care and that's and
there's also you know there's just
things that I'm not medically trained to
do
um so I didn't really feel like I could
have provided that for him so he was
ready to go home you know I think he
must have been about four times I got
the call to say oh Dad can go home but
we need to wait for the care package
because he does need care probably three
times a day with his bathing just before
bed and all sorts of common sort of
helping doing some so that I can done
the lunch time just to give him some
food
um but the other personal care I just
wasn't able to do that yeah no Victoria
is important to say that because
obviously that is something that's said
a lot when people say well why do you
need a care package you have a family
that could look after you and you've
given us the bigger picture it is not
that simple
um Elliot Roy you were nodding along to
what Victoria was saying there and Roy I
think you whispered to Ellie we hear
this a lot if this is a this is a common
problem it is and and Victoria I'm so
sorry to hear that story but it it
encapsulates really the problems that
we're facing now and the NHS did its bit
as as much as it could and then of
course it can't look after people when
they're in their own homes that's the
difficulty that we've got and so we look
to our Partners in Care which are
organized by Social Services what you
were wanting was a package from
domiciliary care
domiciliary care and the care sector
generally has about a 160 000 vacancies
at the moment and getting the care
packages in place is super difficult and
that means then of course that that
person is in bed in a hospital for much
longer than need to be something called
deconditioning takes place where they're
they get worse it makes you vulnerable
to things like flu exactly and and as
much as they the hospitals try to avoid
that sort of cross-contamination it's
really very very difficult and and at
the heart of this at the heart of most
of the problems that I'm sure we're
going to hear about this afternoon is
the Victoria example where actually what
we need to fix is social care and and
I'm sure Ellie sees that every day in
her practice Yeah in your practice you
must hear that a lot from families who
you know you're a first Port of Call as
a GP then that patient may go into
hospital and you know people always say
it's difficult to get into hospital it's
difficult to get into GDP but actually
it's difficult to get out of Hospital
absolutely right and people talk now
about patient flow so flowing from
primary care with me
through an ambulance through a hospital
now the other side and it's out the
other side as Victoria's described into
social care that is causing such a
problem with people and it's incredibly
upsetting as well from the human point
of view that this was you know the end
of your Dad's life Victoria and I'm so
sorry that that's sort of how everything
played out and as Roy said you know
Hospital itself is not a good place for
people to be it's great when you're
acutely unwell and my Hospital
colleagues sort people out but then to
sit there and not to have family around
and deconditioning as Roy said allows
unfortunately this very sad end of life
situation to play out and what I think
we'll also hear this afternoon as well
is this story could have been different
in another part of the country we have a
postcode Lottery there could have been a
different social care issue somewhere
else there may have had better staff and
actually it's not a homogeneous system
and this didn't have to happen yeah
Victoria thank you so much for speaking
up for
um your family your dad and other
families like you who are going through
the same thing in the National Health
Service Anastasia from Leeds is on the
line now Anastasia has cerebral palsy
and Anastasia you've been on the NHS
waiting list for nearly three years for
treatment that is absolutely correct and
I feel absolutely infuriates you don't
feel like I'm losing the will to live to
Corona phrase
um I I mean as you said I've got
cerebral palsy and for what I'm
concerned about is that I've got this I
will say it because it puts it in
context I have a it's not easy to say
but I have a Urological condition and I
just want it fixed and I'm I'm not
receiving any social care I'm not
receiving any support unfortunately I
come from a care background through no
fault of my own because my mother put me
in an institution at the age of two
weeks old and so the support isn't there
I have to fight or always for myself and
in fact
I was once called up for um for the
appointment because I will say that
Botox isn't only for as you know it's
not only for cosmetic reasons and to
have to have this um procedure and um a
second time and he said oh we didn't
realize that you um had several cerebral
palsy you said you don't actually get
the their act together we need to joined
up thinking it varies I've lived in many
areas throughout in different areas
throughout the country it all often
depends on who you speak to and I don't
feel uh listened to when it comes to
social care it depends on whether
somebody has the ability to do this to
do the assessment or not and even if you
do have an assessment then you you don't
necessarily get
um your needs met so you you know I I
don't know what to do and and what
worries me is the fact that the
situation to me and for others can
actually get worse and you know I
believe that my condition is getting
worse and worse and worse
Anastasia I can hear how upset you are I
just want to go to Dr Ellie at this
point because look Anastasia is at her
wit's ends waiting three years for
treatment which will be no doubt
Anastasia correctly if I'm wrong classed
as non-urgent I mean you know there are
six million people currently uh waiting
for treatment in the UK Anastasia making
up that number what advice would you
give to Anastasia because she doesn't
feel like she's getting any support it
is urgent I mean I'm not I'm not I'm
sorry Anastasia's I meant I mean by the
nhsa because it was non-urgent but of
course it's urgent to you it's affecting
your life or I would say a couple of
things I mean first of all speak to your
GP and make sure the referral has gone
through I know that sounds ridiculous
but we're all human and we're relying on
sort of Technology as well and sometimes
referrals don't go through so deaf
definitely make sure see what your GP
can do in terms of the referral the
other thing is speak to Pals who are the
patient advisory so advocacy service
within hospitals and see what's
happening with your appointment and see
you know see if you can make sure
because obviously as you've rightly said
you know this isn't just a health
problem that needs fixing there's a
health problem that need fixing that
then infects your employment your
quality of life what care package you
need and actually if this was sorted out
then you would need probably need less
help from elsewhere yes exactly this is
a system problem and you know we we call
them interfaces where one bit of the
service joins up to the next bit and
it's it's like people people trip over
the joint in the paving stones on the
patio they trip over the joins and the
services as well and it's so often that
you get these service interfaces that
let you down yeah okay let's bring in
Arnold from Birmingham who's on the line
uh who is a big fan of the NHS and is
disappointed that it's got to this place
and all tell me what you want to say
today
well basically basically I feel
the institution itself is absolutely
magnificent where most countries are
jealous of iron in chess
and the present government for the last
12 years
has not funded enough because it seems
as if they want to break the system and
privatize and privatization just means
shareholders make money instead of the
energy serving the people look what
happened in the USA I was involved in
surgery first in 2008 I had a heart
attack and the treatment I received was
Immaculate the ambulance got to me
within five minutes
okay I had surgery last November and
quite serious surgery I got all my
prostrate
and the nurses literally worked their
guts out
and
to now say to them they they don't
deserve a pay right
it it just I just believe that we are
the fifth richest country in the world
and we can't afford to pay our nurses
a salary they can live on
if you're just joining us here on Sky
News we are discussing the state of the
National Health Service NHS crisis it's
your say today we're handling the
program over to you get in touch with us
0208 167 double two double O whether you
work within the NHS or you've had
experience recently using it good or bad
we want to hear from you we're exploring
everything that's going on in the NHS
service at the moment that was Arnold
from Birmingham who is very
complementary of the NHS and received
great treatment
um let's speak to Tony from Preston and
he is talking about physio appointments
the waiting times are ridiculous Tony
talk to me about why you need one and
how long you've been waiting
well I've been playing sport for over 60
years and since 2003 I've had three new
hips an ankle fused a cartilage out and
tendons done in my shoulder and I've
never waited more than a month to be
seen and never waited for more than
three months for an operation with four
different surge surgeons
I had an accolades injury on the 3rd of
October I'm basically struggling to walk
so I went to my doctor on the 8th of
October and I was off with a physio
appointment on the 14th through the 5th
of December which was over two months
later I couldn't get a physio
appointment at the local hospital
so I got a physio or a call with a
private physio an appointment for the
4th of December
on the 4th of December they then said
we're canceling your physio appointment
and we can offer you another one on the
17th of February so it's took four
months to get a an appointment and I
don't know whether that's going to go
ahead in the meantime I needed a scam on
the ankle
so I only got me scan last week which
was the 17th of January three months to
get a scan it's absolutely appalling and
I'm now waiting to see a surgeon so I
rang the Orthopedics at the local
hospital and they told me it could be
two to three months and after that it
would I would get an appointment for a
for an operation in either 12 to 18
months so if I'm lucky I'm going to get
an appointment uh or get something done
in my ankle and it's going to take two
years to do that
feared intimate taxis for 57 years I
need to be active for me on sensanity
and mental health it's doing me no good
at home
um I'm I'm so disappointed with the uh
with the waiting list now it's
absolutely terrible yeah Tony you won't
be on your own in that two years to to
get your ankle sorted like you said it's
your physical health is also your mental
health you want to be mobile right you
can be mobile you're just being made to
wait for two years but it's actually
made you go private hasn't it well I'm
seriously thinking of going private no
it's not only principles
um but I'm struggling to walk and I just
can't put up with this any longer so you
know when you've paid all your taxes you
should be able to get an operation like
I've had for the last well 20 years as I
told you I've had six operations with
the NHS and it's been absolutely superb
service but now I can't even get the
scam can't even get an appointment with
a surgeon and certainly it's going to be
too long for me to get an actual
operation Roy why isn't someone like
Tony prioritize because
you know I suppose you don't want to
compare ailments or you know anything
like that but you know you might look at
an ankle and go well it's not urgent but
again for Tony like Anastasia said for
these people it is urgent it's affecting
their life see it's for everybody it's
an important thing I mean you can't make
a comparability you know between people
and their troubles I mean Ellie I'm sure
we'll talk about an Achilles tendon I
mean it sounds to me like that needs to
be built with more urgently than just
waiting for a scan but the the situation
is this the NHS is like a a big
production line you know sick and poorly
people go in one end and hopefully happy
and fixed up people come out the other
and it doesn't take much to disrupt that
production line and that's what's
Happening Here the production line is
bunged up because we've got people in
hospital that we can't get home we don't
have enough staff on the wards with the
NHS is still struggling with covid I
mean most of us think Kobe it's over but
it's not for the NHS were in the middle
of a flu season which is one of the most
horrendous flu Seasons I think we've
seen for a long time and of course on
top of that we've got the disruption of
the strikes so when you get that kind of
disruption in the system it has a
knock-on effect so if you take something
like a scan if if the hospital is
preoccupied with scanning people who are
already in hospital who've been admitted
there isn't the capacity and this is a
world we're going to hear a lot this
afternoon the NHS doesn't have the
capacity to deal with the problems and
there's lots of reasons for that and
we'll no doubt talk about them later on
but this is a capacity issue there
should be enough Headroom in the system
to say to outpatients who want to scan
come in but at the moment the capacity
is full really by impatience yeah
absolutely and I'm sure you know about
sort of figures for the number of
physiotherapy jobs that are vacant at
the moment now interestingly we've
mentioned already postcode Lottery this
is not a story that I would recognize as
a patient Journey from my practice
because where I work we have what's
called a community musculoskeletal
service so actually people see
physiotherapists very quickly they at
least speak to them very quickly and
likewise myself referral absolutely and
likewise my patients do not wait three
or four months for a scan on an Achilles
it's actually quite quick yes they might
wait for surgery but the process would
have been started so again this is back
to the fact that we have areas where we
have a really good gold standard of care
but there's no mechanism for other areas
to learn or to copycat those Services
you know Tony like when you listen to
that you're a victim of where you live
in terms of it's a postcode Lottery as
to how long you will wait what care you
will receive and when
oh we lost it Tony still with us yeah
I'm still with you yeah yeah Tony you
know that must be very frustrating to
hear that it's a postcode Lottery
essentially you're a victim of where you
live
yeah I mean it's terrible isn't it when
you think about it because I mean I only
live two miles from the local hospital
so I could go anywhere to get to occur I
would go anywhere to get uh to get the
treatment and that's what I've had to do
with me with my hips over the years and
obviously it's a shortage of stuff isn't
it you know there's no way that
um I can get uh an appointment with the
physio at the local hospital which are
employed by the um which are employed by
the uh NHS I mean this privacy go into
other areas so could Tony say to his
doctor look I'm not getting any Joy with
the hospital you've recommended me to
I've been on a waiting list of two years
can I go somewhere else price of choice
you can go you can choose to go
somewhere else of course you can and and
but what happens here you must see this
a lot you know a scan is a scan you know
it's a picture it it so what's the scan
for is it is it for a diagnosis yes it
is okay the diets are diagnosis knows
what well if you've got a ruptured
Achilles tendon then you can't get about
then clearly that scan should take
priority over a scan that's just maybe
checking I know post-operative or you
know it's it's a it's a way of
prioritizing the scans and and and and
it exists the difficulty we've got is
the NHS is so busy at the moment the
whole lot seems to me to have imploded
yeah okay um we've been talking about
waiting times and we've also been
talking a lot here on Sky News about
response times ambulance response times
as guys Becky Johnson has been at the uh
West Midlands ambulance uh Service uh
control center for quite a few days now
she's been out and about with the teams
as well it's in Dudley and Becky what's
happening right there there right now we
keep hearing about these lengthening
response times talk to me about your
experience there in the control center
well they are still very busy of course
the pressures this winter have been
unprecedented we know that but
nationally we've heard today that the
waiting time at hospitals that
ambulances are having to wait before
they can hand over to a e has fallen
slightly on last month and that's what
we're seeing here at West Midlands
Ambulance Service I've got the latest
numbers last month in December the
longest a West Midlands Ambulance
Service ambulance waited outside a
hospital was 32 hours and 57 minutes
quite extraordinary now this month the
longest is 11 hours 57 minutes so quite
an improvement now I'm told there are a
number of reasons for that firstly
they're seeing fewer cases of flu fewer
cases of covid and thankfully fewer
poorly children with strep a but they're
also doing things in the hospitals So
speaking to the paramedics here there
are now Advanced paramedic teams in some
of the busier a e departments across the
Midlands who have set up essentially in
in spaces within those a new units
working alongside Healthcare assistance
from the hospital so that ambulances can
hand over patients and these these
Advanced paramedics could be looking up
to around looking after around 12
patients at a time so they haven't quite
been admitted to hospital but at least
that ambulance can get then get back out
on the road because of course the worry
is that there are simply no ambulances
left to respond to category 1 calls
because they're all queuing outside
Hospitals now they're working all the
time here with the live data on the
walls and uh just a brief look at that
basically the more green there is the
better the more red there is the more
worrying you can see it's a bit of a
mixed picture today and I've got some
live data on this iPad here that's
telling me that at the moment the
longest wait an ambulance has had
outside a hospital there's one ambulance
at Shrewsbury hospital that's been there
at two hours and 16 minutes another
ambulance at the same hospital has been
there two hours and 10 minutes I mean
you know we're talking about things
getting better but better then really
bad isn't necessarily good and
ambulances should be handing patients
over within 15 minutes well looking at
these this data there are at least six
ambulances in the West Midlands that
have been waiting outside a e
departments for over an hour and are
still waiting there so still the
pressure is acute but perhaps just not
quite as bad as last month oh Becky
thank you Becky there with a snapshot of
what's going on inside the West Midlands
ambulance service call center you can
only imagine the pressure in that Center
when they're getting calls in and
they're trying to find an ambulance
that's free to get to those emergency
calls let's say from Carol in Sheffield
um she's got a good story for us her dad
broke his leg last week he was seen and
sorted including a trip in an ambulance
inside five hours Carol tell us more yes
exactly he a 90 better he fell on the
ice last Friday and it was about quarter
to ten in the morning mum called an
ambulance I wasn't there
we don't quite remember how long the
owners took to come but no one no one
was standing around saying where's the
ambulance where's the ambulance
at quarter to ten and
at least us and the accidents emergency
department and that was so that's half
past two that's about five and a half
hours actually and they do live a long
way away they live 12 miles away from us
had that on as well pardon me he called
me to say that Dad was comfortable that
he'd been treated for his pain that it
had all his x-rays it had
helped us
seen obviously by the nurse and no staff
and the first he'd also been seen by the
accident emergency doctor a lovely lady
called Francis and she I spoke to her
again as well as this this verse and
they'd already met his diagnosis that
preliminary care plan intended at that
time and he didn't I didn't actually go
straight to the ward but it wasn't very
long until he went on to the water
following that he added up that was um
Friday he had his operation on Sunday
yes I was an operation on Sunday and all
of his treatment has been a absolutely
brilliant it's all gone really Swimming
by the nurses on the ward have been
fabulous and I can't we can't praise
them highly enough and okay in the olden
days five and a half hours might have
seemed like a long time but let's be
straight and let's give them some some
credit where it's due to people who are
still managing to do a fabulous job
because they must get very Deborah lines
when they hear negative Stories the
whole time yeah 100 Carol people always
want to talk more about the bad things
than they do about the good things
that's just the nature of us as people
isn't it but when the NHS gets it right
it is the best in the world what Ellie
was saying earlier you know it is it is
patchy it's not horribly bad everywhere
and it's not super good everywhere there
are differences it's good sometimes I
mean this this is this is classic the
operation was well within the nice
guidelines and and this is how it's
supposed to be done but it depends a lot
there are a lot of other factors I mean
first of all there's a demography of the
area where the hospital is does it have
a lot of very elderly frail people like
for example on the south coast there's
there's a higher incidence of elderly
people there so that makes a difference
it's where the hospital is and you often
find hospitals who are in coastal areas
find it very difficult to recruit and so
that's a problem if they don't have the
staff and so if there's a lot of
compounding factors that sit outside the
hospital that impact what happens inside
the hospital and I just going back to
the report we we had about the ambulance
service the the the flu the numbers for
flu are are starting to drop and what we
find with flu epidemics is they're a
slow burn to start with and then they
compound and suddenly you swamp with
people with the flu but when it burns
itself out they drop off a cliff so
hopefully we might be seeing the end of
the flu I mean I would say that that
story we heard I would say and obviously
I'm biased because I work in within the
NHS I would say that is more common than
people having I would say that is more
the normal people having a bad
experience so in my GP surgery we take
Google reviews and NHS choices reviews
and the majority of them are incredibly
positive both regarding the clinical
staff and the Administration staff and I
would say that as you say you know bad
news makes headlines and people talk
about sort of those issues much more but
the majority because people working with
the NHS want to do a good job we in the
main are practicing gold standard care
within sort of the limited resources
that we have and I would say that in the
main
um we have we have good experiences no
one comes to work to keep people waiting
I'm just I'm just thinking back to Tony
we were speaking to from Preston who's
been waiting two years for that ankle
scan and the issue of fairness in terms
of we mentioned postcode Lottery how is
it fair that somebody in your area Ellie
gets five-star treatment great reviews
on Google for the hospital or the GB
surgery someone in Tony's area is having
a terrible time whether it's getting a
GP appointment having to go in an
ambulance and waiting for hours so again
that's so that's partly to do with what
Roy mentioned which is really
interesting actually about the
demography of Staff around the country
so I give you an example from my own
personal life so I work in a GP practice
which is really really good I'm a
patient in a GP practice which is really
not good actually and the person within
my family who's got a chronic condition
we've taken them out of that GP surgery
and put them in one half a mile down the
road registered there so we can get that
person very good care and yet the GP
surgery at the bottom of my road I don't
get good care now that's the same
demography it's the same area
and there is this terrible patchy
service it's all about shopping around
and doing your research
you know we do that in other areas of
life people don't change doctors you
know
all the evidence is if you look at the
numbers you know once you're with a GP
you stay and you just kind of put up
with it should it be that way it would
be a bit more proactive I mean you know
we should have uh one of these uh uh
websites where you can ship advisor yeah
TripAdvisor for health but I mean well I
think more tools are becoming available
for people to see how their GP is doing
whether it's league tables or reviews
um right we're going to leave it there
just a reminder of the number to call
um 0208 167 double two double A to have
your say on the NHS today good and bad
we want to hear all stories whether you
work within the service or whether you
are receiving treatments from it uh
later tonight there's a special debate
here on Sky News on the huge issues
facing the National Health Service We'll
be asking can the NHS survive it's uh
this evening right here on Sky News at
seven o'clock
well still to come here on our NHS
special phone in program
uh we'll be taking more of your calls
coming up next uh what do you think of
the continued NHS strike action as I
said get in touch 0208 167 double 200
that's the number to call
[Music]
foreign
there's always more to the news than a
headline we want to discover to delve a
little deeper to find out what's really
going on explanation analysis the people
at the heart of every story I'm Neil
Patterson and this is this guy News
Daily podcast Alex Crawford joining us
now from Ukraine their personal
possessions are all scattered around the
place our economics and data editor Ed
Conway try and make sense of at the big
numbers for us things can change
incredibly quickly that's what they have
done so by the end we'll hopefully all
understand what's going on in the world
just that little better available
whatever you get your podcast
foreign
[Music]
uh welcome back to NHS crisis your say
all afternoon here on Sky News we are
taking your calls and giving you the
chance to show your views on the state
of the National Health Service don't
forget the numbers call today if you
want to have your say here with us on
the show 0208 167 double two double o
uh right let's get back to the calls
we're now going to talk about the
ongoing strike action within the Health
Service no end in sight to that more
dates announced for a February and March
let's talk to Vincent he is in
Birmingham he's a retired consultant uh
geriatrician and Vincent you don't
support the strikes tell us why
oh thank you very much
um let me say that it is not that I
don't support the strike and it's not
that I don't support the pay increase
for the hospital workers what I am
against is the timing
um
I retired as a consultant geriatrician
in September 2021
while I was in service
there was we were always complaining
about inadequate remuneration for the
work we do and at that time we were
actually considering going on strike and
all that
um this time I am against the timing of
the strikes because
the government we have now in place the
government of Rishi sunak is virtually a
new one last year we had three prime
ministers all in one go and he is here
so far he I'm not convinced that he is
doing wrong in fact I am satisfied with
his plan of action to revamp the NHS
and I think because they are new and
because they are just settling down we
should allow them time to settle before
we begin to go on strike you do know
what people are going to be saying at
home some people at home are going to be
saying look you know Rishi Cena might be
you but the conservatives aren't you
they've been in power for over a decade
and we've had prime minister after prime
minister uh promising to to boost the
NHS to invest in the NHS to bring it up
to where it was
um but in the last you know 10 to 12
years the NHS has deteriorated so the
government isn't new it might be a new
prime minister but it's the same
government
yeah I agree I do agree but he appears
to have a new sense and a new way of
doing things
um from what he has outlined I I still
think that we should give him maybe one
year two years to see how he does
um do you think he should talk to the
National Health Service workers who are
striking because what we're hearing from
um those on the picket lines and I know
you don't just you don't agree with
these strikes necessarily the timing of
them but what we're hearing from those
on the picket lines is that the
government won't even engage with them
they won't even talk to them about their
demands whether well not their demands
their ass whether it be about pay or
conditions they're not engaging I think
Rishi sunak if he is shiny and new and
getting to grips with it he should sit
down and talk to them actively engage
with them about pay
yes I am not
a spokesperson
um what I understand Rishi sunak did was
to set up a peer review committee that
made some recommendations all of which
he accepted
um every one of us we all adults every
one of us knows that this government as
it is now doesn't have much money the
nursing staff start started by
requesting a pay increase of 19 percent
um he can't I don't think my knowledge
I'm not an economist but I don't think
he can give them that and give the
ambulance drivers and give the Border
agency workers and everybody that will
lead to severe inflation in this country
and we'll know what that will amount you
that is what I'm saying yes I agree he
should talk to anybody who has a reason
for wanting to go on strike he shouldn't
avoid them he should talk to every
individual that is part of his job
description I'm sure
um but in terms of every one or for
everybody expecting the money they are
demanding in this current circumstance I
I don't think I think it's a very hard
ask yeah that's my impression I get it
Vincent if you give in to one you have
to give in to all like you said so many
people on strike at the moment we're
only talking about the NHS today you've
got Railway workers and you know
teachers considering going on strike and
gosh the environment agency there are so
many people going on strike at the
moment I completely take your point give
in to one you have to give in to them oh
let's talk to Gavin from Kent and Gavin
had a stroke and had an amazing
experience within the NHS and believes
that the NHS staff should be paid more
Gathering first of all how are you talk
to you about your experience that's too
bad thank you funny enough videos just
left my house
what was that sorry I said funny enough
the physio's just left my home about 10
minutes we call you at the right time
yeah talk to me about the experience you
had in hospital then why are you such a
good part in London up the West End on
the night out for our anniversary our
wedding anniversary all of a sudden I
started feeling ill when I went over
like a tree and um she realized I was
having a stroke and she phoned an
ambulance I was there in like three
minutes within 20 minutes I was having
um I was having Care Medical Care
fortunately enough where's right on top
of the hospital within half an hour I
was having proper care so I had an acute
stroke but
um it saved my life and then I can't I
can't say the word but I I had to do a
cranioscopy which means they've took off
my skull off my head
um
um so they've done that
I don't know who's ringing me in now
um I mean Gavin you know you said it
yourself you owe the NHS your life so
for you money money is No Object talk to
me about some of the the staff that that
you met and how they looked up I've been
in five hospitals
yeah five in total and I think Richie
soon actually going to pack an overnight
bag and going in a cute stroke unit and
watch how many jobs do nurses have to do
in an hour
let's see it with his own eyes
personally or one of the MPS go in there
and take a bed for the night and go and
have a look
and go and live it a little bit
only 25 of nursing shifts are fully
staffed yeah well your College of
Nursing so when when they're working on
tremendous pressure
I mean the nurses that I see are running
around doing five jobs at a time
and like I said I'll thank I'll thank
them all because I think they've been
absolutely brilliant in NHS personally
that's my experience and I think we
should find the money and give them the
money
yeah I mean Gavin you're not alone you
do hear from so many people who have had
whether it's life-saving treatment or
you know
um bringing you life into the world in a
maternity unit you know people have so
many positive stories about the NHS I've
got nothing but good to say personally
yeah yeah no I I I can fully understand
why
okay well let's get a sense now of the
pressure on NHS staff and the reason
that they have launched uh this
industrial action uh Paul Turner
paramedic for the Northwest Ambulance
Service he's also a deputy Branch
Secretary at the GMB Union
um Paul that's just one of the many
positive
um stories we're getting here at Sky
News Today on our your say program uh
people value the NHS and you know a lot
of people say you can't put a price on
you know saving lives but actually you
can when it comes to paying staff
properly and enabling them to work in
better conditions all around the NHS the
staffing needs investment that's why
you're striking
yeah so the strikes are based on two
elements the first element is about the
public safety and the second part is
about the 10 years of austerity faced by
NHS workers
um and I appreciate we are not the only
ones on strike but I can only talk about
the NHS because that's what I work for
that's what I'm interested in and you
know we we miss other very important
Services out there that are not eligible
for strike but again from this
government we're rewarded pretty much
nothing as a pay rise because gas
electric mortgage rates rent rates they
all go up but our wages never match
inflation now I'm not saying we deserve
an inflation busting pair eyes but it
needs to at least match
um inflation because of the 10-year
austerity that we've experienced you
know I listened to Vincent the first
gentleman that was on
um and I I you know
I don't agree with what he's saying
there's no right time to take a strike
nobody in the NHS ever wants to go on
strike we're here to look after the
patients that we serve but every single
day when we're trying to do that because
of the underfunding and the lack of
resources we've got We are failing every
single day and now it's come to a point
where enough is enough an NHS staff
can't carry the burden any longer people
are waiting hours and hours for
ambulances which is not acceptable
there's often when I'm at work my
colleagues are at work right across the
UK where we're hearing our radios
pinging saying there's category one
emergency is outstanding whilst we're
stood outside corridors or in a
completely different area to where we
should be it's not unusual for me to
travel an hour an hour and a half to an
incident on blue lights and Sirens to
get to someone who needs us because
there's no resources available in that
area and that's because of the amount of
under-resourcing that we're facing
you know it's really stressful at the
moment in the NHS you know you don't get
a break from it your 12 hour shift or
your eight hour shift can turn into 14
15 hours easily
um you're lucky if you get anything to
eat or drink during your shift because
you stood on corridors
um and that poor patient when you've
gone home is still sat potentially on
that Corridor or in your cold ambulance
um and you come back in the following
shift and the patient's still there
because they've not moved that is not
acceptable at all moving forward
I hear people saying there's no money
for you know pay Rises things like that
but we managed to find money for MP
expenses for instance they claim more in
expenses that the 999 callers get paid
working for the NHS taking notes 999
calls
um it's outrageous that we're carrying
on in in the way we are yeah and now we
are struggling to recruit into those
areas
um because other
service providers or their jobs are
paying more than what you can working
for the NHS which fair play to them
because they are looking after their
workers and people could say well leave
the job if you don't want to do it go
work there but then who's going to do
the job that I that I do and one of the
other things that really frustrates
people is how degrading it is being
called an ambulance driver
um I'm a highly educated uh Medical
Professional I've done three years at
University to obtain a degree like all
of my colleagues have and even our
EMTs and dispatchers and call takers and
everybody else across the NHS you now
need to have minimum qualifications to
be to be eligible for those roles so to
be called ambulance drivers I I think
it's a bit of a kick a kick in the teeth
and that's coming directly from the
government
yeah Paul I can sense the frustration in
your voice you know you're living and
breathing this and you know a phrase
that I heard earlier this week you know
people aren't dying because NHS Workers
are striking and it's just Workers are
striking because people are dying is
what you're talking about yeah that's
correct a recent GMB survey our members
believe that patients are now dying
because of the delays that's not me
saying that that's you know 20
000 GMB members across the ambulance
service saying that you know we are
facing this every single day and you
know I don't want to be on strike every
day I'm on strike I lose pay and write
me so because I'm not providing that
service
um however I will never get that money
back and then rightly someone won't get
that money back but I'm doing it because
otherwise
because it won't be here we cannot get
staff we are massively underfunded and
massively under-resourced and I'm not
going to get on to how badly we're
treated through the covid pandemic we
didn't even have suitable PPE which
again were wasted millions and millions
of pounds a year storing it out of date
in a warehouse
you have to remind yourself why you
still do this job why do you still do it
I do the job because I love helping
patients there's nothing better than
saving someone's life you know
delivering a child you know preventing
that potential death when you get there
there's nothing more rewarding rewarding
than that and that side of the job I
absolutely love and that's why I
continue to do it but the politics
behind it it's just it we've had enough
I cannot stress it our members have had
enough I've had enough people are
leaving in droves we cannot recruit
because you can work elsewhere and get
more money or the equivalent for less
stress it's all the stress that you take
home with you you go home after 12 4 14
15 hours knowing that that patient's
still going to be sat there in the
morning it's just not fair and it's not
right and and I again listen to Vincent
about giving rushy soon Knack a chance
no we've had a Tory government now for
too long we need a change not very
political to be fair I don't really not
really interested who gets there but we
need to have a change we need somebody
in power that actually cares about the
public
um Paul thank you stay with us for just
a moment
um a really impassioned conversation
there with Paul we could just feel your
passion for the NHS service and your
frustration about what you're going
through she says you studied for three
years do this job to save people's lives
and you're not able to do your job
properly and let's speak to Jason in
Newcastle now um Jason was in a
motorbike accident and spent five months
in an NHS hospital and Jason what was
your experience in that hospital because
because what I can see from the notes my
producer has given me you feel like a
lot of money and time is wasted in
hospitals
I would have to agree with you then so
um
like I said I was there for just over
five months in in hospital and I was
between two hospitals so I was initially
enlisted to a Scottish hospital
um where they carried out the surgery
and things like that today and and then
I was transferred to an English hospital
to be repatriated course at the home now
the first thing that
comes to mind anywhere is the fact that
it was cheaper to use a private
ambulance than what it was to use an NHS
ambulance which I thought was staggering
um so that was that was that was out um
saw straight away now when I was part of
in the English Hospital the
hospital I would say a lot of wasted
money now I'm from a timber frame
background in the private sector where
things were basically a production line
and you know you had to work for what
you had to get now in the NHS that I'm
led to believe anywhere from from stuff
when I was when I was in hospital that
when you take a day off from work you
actually paid for the deal from work and
you just don't perceive a shift
enhancements whereas in a regular job
you would lose your first three days and
things like that and so there will be a
waste of money for me anyway so you'll
be paid everything by your shift
enhancement for going to for going to
work but you don't actually turn up and
there was World managers and things like
that which would take in from what I
believe anyway from my research so they
were like grade seven or grade band
seven or band eight
um 43 000 pounds a year plus
um walking round and I don't know what
the situation was but they're basically
tearing pennies off using PBA and things
like that to walk around asking patients
how they were doing then tearing it off
again and putting it in the bin and then
carrying on walking around those things
myself right well I don't understand
what your purpose is exactly within the
hospital and so I don't see why you'll
be paying 43 000 pounds a year for you
to be doing what you're doing I don't
really understand with that
um I ended up having a few meetings with
the ward manager on on my particular
Ward
um about how staff will behaving
um how for instance there would be four
sisters on a ward uh two nurses and say
for instance three carers
um to look after the patients now while
my water wasn't a particularly busy Ward
and so I can't speak for the for the
whole hospital I've got no doubt that in
other Awards uh things are really busy
like a previous channel members here and
above the stroke award I've got no adult
that it's a it's a really busy Ward but
on the ward that I was on you couldn't
get staff for loving the money through
Monday or Friday but yet when it came to
a weekend when there was enhancements or
time and a half rates of paying double
times for a Sunday you couldn't get
moved for nurses
um on the ward you know so I've got the
the thing to myself but there's another
amount of money that doesn't need to be
spent
um
okay Jason well what you're talking
about is accountability and you did the
right thing you asked questions you
asked to speak to the wall manager about
what you were seeing and that's probably
a good example to set in terms of asking
questions whether it's about your care
or the environment you're in uh within
the NHS let's quickly speak to Anthony
from Chessington who's been hanging on
um Anthony
um I'm really sorry to hear he had a
seizure two weeks ago
um and your ambulance weight went from
two to nine hours so you went back to
bed and woke up with concerns
over Cardiac Arrest what happened
basically what happened is I had a
seizure and
um I was in the hallway and
I had a seizure in the hallway and my my
wife had to call for the ambulance and
then basically he's waited quite a while
for the ambulance to come out and um
when they came out after quite a while
um they came and did tests on me and
said yes basically
um your
symptoms of having a heart attack
and they took me to hospital and I was
still waiting in the ambulance for quite
a while because the lift on the back of
the ambulance stopped working and I was
stuck in the ambulance for quite a while
as well
and
um when
um the people came and said we won't we
can't take you out of the bed in case
you do have a cardiac arrest
um you're gonna have to wait in the
ambulance and then when I got into the
hospital I was waiting for five hours
before even anybody come and did any
checks on me anything basically
Anthony it must have been an extremely
extremely worrying time for you and your
family I'm just going to bring in
um Paul Turner as well um from the
Northwest Ambulance Service a paramedic
A GMB Union Deputy Branch Secretary I
mean Paul these stories will not be
unfamiliar to you you know you
experience them day in day out I
appreciate you staying with us because I
know you've got to go and do the school
run because you know you work and you
have a family talk to me about how all
of this is affecting you personally
because you know we talk about pay and
conditions this is your work life but
you know how much is it affecting your
your day-to-day life your personal life
it's very difficult it affects all of my
colleagues exactly the same you know we
you can't really arrange anything after
work so if you you know due to finish at
seven o'clock in the evening and you've
got to get your children you know our
partners might work night shifts because
we're on days here you're working
opposite you you can't guarantee you're
going to be home at seven o'clock
because you might then be stood at in
the hospital for another four or five
hours
um so it becomes a lot of stressful
stressfulness that shouldn't really be
there
um listening to those four individuals
there that have experienced such bad
Care by the NHS not the staff but
because of the under-resourcing it is
just not acceptable it really isn't and
you know I I hand on heart tell you now
none of the NHS staff want to be on
strike we really don't we want the
government to get around the table give
us a plan of how the NHS is going to
look in two or five years time and also
talk about pay we need to understand
what the government are going to do
moving forward it cannot carry on like
this and I fundamentally believe that we
are privatizing the NHS through the back
door I know every single day we put out
private ambulances every day responding
to our calls because we don't have
enough staff we don't have enough people
there so they have to bring in private
providers Paul we have to leave you
there and you have to go thank you so
much for talking to us about your
experiences uh we'll have more calls
after the break
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
hello this is NHS crisis your say I'm
Sarah J Meade with a special program
here on Sky News this afternoon getting
your views on the state of Our National
Health Service
Hospital waiting times are the longest
in history with thousands of surgeries
canceled as the Health Service struggles
to cope
ambulance response times are the slowest
on record and crews are spending entire
shifts parked outside hospitals waiting
to offload patients
a poll suggests a third of people are
unable to book a GP appointment and the
111 phone service is facing
unprecedented demand
foreign
with the NHS on its knees industrial
action is spreading in a deepening
dispute with the government do you
support the Striking workers or disagree
with their action
and if you have a positive story to
share we want to hear it whether you
work within the NHS or you want to talk
about the treatment you've received we
want to hear from you this afternoon to
have your say call 0208
1672200 and you could be on air with us
this afternoon
[Music]
foreign
you're watching NHS crisis your say
today Sky News is launching a special
project it's a year-long project with
two leading think tanks to try and find
solutions to the crisis that is
currently gripping the Health Service
well all afternoon we're going to be
taking your calls and giving you the
chance to share your views about your
National Health Service good or bad
we're going to get into the course in
just a moment but alongside me in the
studio we have Roy Lilly who is a health
policy analyst and former Vice chairman
of West Surrey and Northeast Hampshire
health authority alongside Roy a
familiar face to you here at Sky News Dr
Ellie Cannon GP and author don't forget
the number you need to call this
afternoon if you want to have your say
with us here on Sky News it's 0208 167
double two double O and
we are going to get back to the callers
Amy is first up Amy is from Essex
and Amy and we're going to talk in part
about Staffing in this uh portion of the
phone in and your experiences of having
a baby
within the NHS tell me about where you
nearly had the baby
so originally I'd planned to go to a
mid-rise free LED unit
um but sadly during the pregnancy
um the unit actually got closed down
because they were staffing issues
so my closest hospital is an hour away
which obviously is a bit of a concern if
there's anything wrong with baby your
baby or you during labor
um and then luckily it did open just
prior to but because of the staffing
issues they had to do it on like a day
by day basis
um and then I ended up having to go to
my main hospital which was an hour away
sorry
I can hear said baby in the background
is she what's her name
um she is Lily
um she made quite an entrance into the
world's lesser because I was like I say
end up having to go to the hospital but
because I'd not been there for any
appointments they didn't have anything
to say like with you already or anything
like that so I was sent to a day
assessment unit rather than the
Maternity Ward and I ended up actually
nearly having her in the corridor
because there wasn't anywhere for me to
go
oh my word well yeah we're thankful that
this story has a happy ending yeah nice
and Lively in the background that's good
have a happy ending but Amy that's not
concerning you know in terms of you
having to go to a hospital an hour away
you didn't know where to go you're
wandering around the hospital yeah
throughout your maternity care yeah and
what had it been like up until that
point because obviously we hear about a
shortage of midwives and the pressure
they're under as well you're meant to
have um I was told you're meant to have
a named Midwife which is what they tell
you you're booking appointment I never
actually saw the same one after I'd had
her
um I was I was due to be stitched up but
I was actually left for about three
hours after having her between getting
stitched up due to a shift change
um but the ladies who did end up coming
to do my stitches apologize profusely it
was no fault for her own she was very
honest which I appreciate she just said
I'm really sorry we're so understaffed
and everyone's worked out that you get
more money and less responsibility by
becoming an agency member of staff so
when they do a changeover rather than it
being like a half hour this is who's who
this is where's where it took him a lot
longer and obviously people slipped
through the cracks
which is not what you need after just
giving birth and I'm gonna bring Roy and
Dr Ellie in on this yeah
um I mean there's so much to unpack from
what Amy's been talking about from yeah
you are meant to have a named Midwife
and anecdotally that doesn't really
happen that often even though it is
meant to happen and then a whole unit
having to be closed down because of a
lack of stuff how does it get to that
point Roy there's not enough midwives we
haven't trained enough midwives there's
not enough midwives we have fewer
midwives per header population the most
comparable Health Care Systems in Europe
and is that because of what we're
hearing in these current strikes it's
conditions and pay yeah look I I think
Paul hit the nail on the head when he
you know he said well why are we here
Paul was our paramedic that yeah before
the break yeah I mean after the we've
got to cast our mind back to life before
kovid to the world banking crisis after
the world banking crisis the NHS had
pretty much Flatline funding under two
percent uplifts a year the NHS needs at
least four percent to run up the down
escalator to keep up with age
populations and developments Innovations
all that kind of stuff so we had 10
years of Flatline very slim funding we
didn't recruit enough people train
enough people build enough hospitals get
enough beds innovate enough all of that
wasn't done we went into covid and we
forget this we went into kovid with
waiting lists at four and a half million
and I remember coming to Sky talking
about four and a half million people
waiting and it was a record and how it
was you know never happened again and
then of course we had 40 000 nurse
vacancies as well it was all building up
at that time then Along Came covid
everything was thrown up in the air now
we're hopefully an inverse Ecom is
coming out the other side of covid the
chickens are coming home to roost
because we don't have enough of anybody
if you look at International comparisons
and you compare us with What's called
the eu-14 that's the oecd countries per
head of population we have fewer doctors
nurses beds diagnostic scanners you name
it then most European countries and
that's when the damage was done now
we're trying to cope with a huge surge
in demand and we just simply don't have
the people and that includes midwives
and you're absolutely right the gold
standard is one mum one Midwife all the
way through it very rarely happens
unfortunately because we just simply
don't have enough people let's bring in
Ezra from Lincoln uh Ezra had pancreatic
cancer but had an amazing experience
with the NHS and Ezra you had to undergo
various operations as well talk to me
about your experience and the level of
care you received
yeah I can praise the NHS uh enough it's
it's
absolutely outstanding the care I
received at my local uh thinking you
know uh Lincolnshire hospitals was
outstanding and professional to the nth
degree
I've had PSA testing before and I know
doctors aren't all that came on them but
at the benefit of the TSA test is where
it shows a spike and previously mine was
zero three zero four which is nothing as
complacent but then after recovered
after Bill turnbull's death it just uh
made me think again about having another
one and this time came back at 8.7 from
the GP from the from the nurse at the of
my local TP surgery who took my blood
test to the GP who immediately got the
result of the test said fill me up asked
me to come in the very next day and did
uh digital rectal examination and then
put me immediately onto the two-week
cancer curwit straight away I've seen
within two weeks at my local hospital I
had an MRI scan I've had a biopsy I had
a bone scan I was I was I was I met the
urologist who told me through the whole
procedure where my cancer was and my
prostrate
um and luckily enough it is still
contained and and I closed captioning
not available
[Music]
yeah that's the gold standard level of
care that's kind of we're talking you
can't mess with cancer
you have to get on do it and that's a
classic how it should be done and I
thought he was when um Ezra wasn't it
was was saying their professionals
they're not Heroes I mean the the staff
you talk about vocation they say yeah
maybe but you know I'm a professional
and I do a professional job and that's
what I want to be known for yeah they
don't want to be clapped they want to be
back absolutely right and I think
there's a real difference I think I
should clarify actually because we
introduced Ezra as having pancreatic
cancer and it sounds like he's actually
had prostate cancer and but I think that
it's important that people realize
because the difference we've had with
people with having ankle injuries versus
something like cancer and maternity
versus something like cancer there have
been Flagship services like the two-week
wait like the stroke Services where
there have been huge amounts of
investment huge amounts of media
interests huge amounts of political
interest which again has added to this
patchy service so thankfully we will
have stories and I'm so pleased to hear
it from Ezra of that absolute gold
standard service from his blood test
going up all the way through to the
treatment versus somebody who's got what
is perceived as a non-urgent ankle
injury
and is really really suffering it's not
urgent to anybody else but them and
that's what we forget you know you have
to start with a patient and work
backwards yeah that's the thing there's
all the statistics or the numbers
involved it's yeah the NHS does have a
quite an interesting program it's called
the girth program it's called getting it
right first time program and it's very
successful because it does look at the
gold standard and try and introduce it
across the NHS and they're making quite
serious Headway I think in trying to
equalize the the way in which people are
treated throughout the country the NHS
is really you know it's a it's a it's a
patchwork
individual organizations you know the
trusts themselves the statutory
Standalone bodies they're all the
independent that's the result of the
Thatcher reforms which in terms of
management was a good thing but in terms
of of standardizing care it's really
quite it's made it extremely fragmented
and well Ezra we're so pleased to hear
that you're doing well and and yeah and
so nice to hear good words about um your
nurse Katie I'm sure all the other
members of staff that you encountered
these names you can't remember because
obviously you're going through a huge
ordeal with prostate cancer and but I
know that you'll remember the faces and
remember the care you got for a lifetime
so Ezra thank you for calling into us
here at Sky News just a reminder if you
do want to get in touch and have your
say this afternoon 0208 167 double two
double O let's talk to Janet now she's
in Lancashire she's actually an ex
practice manager in primary care and
Janet had three spinal surgeries just
last year and because of the problems
you had during those surgeries and
around your care you now have PTSD
um Janet this sounds just awful
um tell us more about it okay yes um hi
um I'd just like to say first of all
before I begin that don't I want to
emphasize that
um I have no criticism against any of
the doctors Consultants or nurses that
um dealt with me during the
um during the time I was in hospitals
that Roy made earlier it's a problem
with the NHS not the staff that work
within it so no you're quite right to
highlight that absolutely I feel that
their uh they're victims of a failing
Health Service just like the patients
are and but I last year
um I've obviously got several stories to
tell but one I wanted to highlight for
Sky News was the 37-hour wait in a e
that I have
um and um I was only at that time I just
had my second spinal surgery I'd have a
two two spinal surgery in 14 days and
I'd only just been discharged and two
days later I went back in in an
ambulance because of complication and I
was Satan into the rapid at a rapid
assessment and treatment service in in
the hospital a e department and a long
long story try and cut it short and
after about six hours there would have a
lot of tests and um and how the cannula
inserted down my arm I was no by mouth
because they thought I may have to
undergo a third surgery after about six
hours I was moved to another part of a e
which at this stage was absolutely
overflowing with patients I've been
taking it in at six six
6 a.m in the morning and this is
probably about midday and I felt so
sorry for the nurses and the doctors and
patients were on the hard trolley beds
and some were just on chairs waiting
um it was honestly it was Dreadful there
weren't enough staff to be covering and
I was lucky enough because I was putting
a little cubicle which had a door some
patients were just
um you know screened off with curtains
um at one stage I was catheterized but
just left I had no pillow I was nil by
mouth
and um I was in the room just literally
on my own I was in a lot of pain with my
back and
um yeah it was very very traumatic and
um one stage uh during the night I had a
commotion and there was a gentleman that
had been brought in and he was drunk and
he's been beaten up and he was given
abuse to the you know the couple of
nurses that were there and I thought you
know there's some people who are very
critically ill there was a gentleman in
a little cubicle next to me and I could
hear him moaning and he he he sounded
really really really very poorly and
um you know the nurses trying to deal
with all these little situations
um during the night a bit well going
towards the early hours of the morning I
um I've been catheterized but the the
nurses only be able to find a small
comforter bag for me and during the
night I felt I felt like I needed to you
know to pass you in and I realized that
the capita bag was full and it was
overflowing so I've got you in on
midnight this summer dressing down on
the sheet
um and um also I tried to take my
dressing gown off because it was wet
with you and and I pulled the catheter
out cold so I pulled the cannula out of
my arm and partly out of my arm so that
that I was bleeding all of them in
actress I was shouting desperately for a
nurse to come and help me and I got um I
got to the stage where I sat I managed
to sit myself up uh burning mine like I
said I was only eight eight days past
surgery and I sat on the edge of the
trolley and and I literally started to
cry I felt so miserable and so you know
depressed and low but I just didn't know
what I could do for myself
I managed to get up and I got outside of
the door and there was warm Healthcare
assistant not a nurse not a staff nurse
a healthcare assistant to at that stage
was looking after seven patients and she
just said look I'm really sorry but
you're going to have to wait no Janet
I'm so sorry to hear about your
experience you know as you said it was
like a horror movie and as a result of
what you went through you know those
surgeries and then that experience in a
e 37 hours yeah
and he came out with PTSD it's a graphic
example isn't it when we hear about
delays you hear from patients who've
experienced that delays and what is
happening the reason it's happened is an
e is chock-a-block because when
ambulances bring people then normally
about 40 percent of people who have
brought in by ambulance have to be
admitted and they get they get treated
in a e they can't move them onto the
wards because the wards are chocker
blocked because as we heard earlier in
the program we can't get the care
packages to get people home safely so
the whole system backs up and that's a
very graphic example of what happens to
to patients and it's a a dreadful
experience for Janet but also that delay
something like something like watchdown
has just explained and a very human way
she's described it and the emotional
impact and possibly the physical impact
as well it's not just the delay there
that's the problem there's then possibly
medical issues and ongoing emotional
issues as a result so we're we're
creating ongoing problems which feed
back into the NHS either because of pain
or because of psychological trauma
um that sort of thing and there is a
management expression but it's called
failure demand it's the demand that's
created by failure in the first time
think people well we've been hearing it
this afternoon here on the special
program that you know people are going
into hospital and having more problems
in there picking up more coming out with
more problems and that's not why you go
into Hospital you go into hospital to
get better to find some yeah to get
sources and let's bring in Fraser from
Maidstone he has um had a more positive
experience and now Fraser you're a
high-risk diabetic
um so you've had you know experience of
the NHS and but you want to tell us a
particular story about your daughter yes
I do yes she's um she's three years old
um about six weeks ago she was in my in
my car going to Nursery uh was coughing
uh coughed up a load of blood I actually
panicked because I've never seen blood
come out of a little little girl's mouth
ever
um stop pulled over a lady who was going
to work who was a nurse for the local
hospital
she said to me Don't Panic it's probably
just the burst blood vessel but go to a
and get it checked out so I literally
turned around when this is Never Off
Duty never options
yeah which was awesome because she can't
move down straight away because when
your little girl's bleeding and you
think the worst uh so I drove the
hospital uh went into a e within 15
minutes I was freeway and he into the
children's Ward and they said yes it's
the first month whistle because the
tonsil is absolutely massive
um got me a consultation within the week
with a consultant at the same hospital
and on Tuesday on the 31st of this month
she goes in to have a tonsils taken out
and that to me
it's better than any Private Hospital
could have done you don't get more
efficient than that no you couldn't
literally
um I'm I've I'm a diabetic and I've got
sarcoidosis which is a a glandular lung
disease and from day one the local
hospital for my whole family myself have
been absolutely incredible they've never
done a you know a thing wrong you can
see them under pressure
um but like they they deal with it
literally
um
I don't know what else I could say it's
really easy you know to get in that
quick for my daughter which was a panic
for me and then usually yeah
um
quite quite an interesting phrase
because uh pediatric anes are a
relatively new I mean not brand new but
they're a relatively new addition to the
NHS where they specialize with children
and I'm pleased it was only tonsilized
you'll have to get the ice cream ready
that's it yes
tonsillitis yes but no yeah I I can see
I I watched the program I can see
everyone's point of view but personally
myself
I haven't got an issue there's things we
can do to change it you know if we all
stood up and said look we I quite
happily pay more to the NHS
um you know I I I I work seven days a
week to provide for my family but I
would quite happily if they're
interested right we'll take a private
program or subsidize programs to pay an
extra whatever it is to help I would
glad to do that private care within the
NHS or would you support something like
tax Rises to to funds well
I I I don't understand how I've lived in
America and I've seen it from that side
as well
um if we if there was a way that we
could if it was attachment to earnings
or something if you had more medical
care I don't know how it works it's
weird but you you pay for what you used
in some sort of form or if there's a way
to do an insurance policy or something
but I would rather use the National
Health Service than try and go private
because it's taking the National Health
Service people into the private that's
right yeah so you look you look at the
programs you read the stories I remember
they're all true doctors have moved to
Dubai because they're getting more money
to work privately than they are in the
NHS now I feel like something's got to
give more money's got to come from
somewhere whether it's people paying
privately I don't think it's just not
money because the industry is I mean I
speak to
um police we speak to ambulance drivers
uh and a lot of hospital staff and they
they are so passionate about their job
more passionate than probably I am about
my job but there is a debate you know
coming probably for the next election
and how we pay for the NHS we pay
through taxes here some people talk
about social insurance look I mean you
take your taxes out of your left hand
pocket and your social insurance out of
your right hand pocket it's still your
trousers you still have to pay and the
cheapest cleanest quickest way to to pay
for the NHS is through our taxes well
but you know as we found this afternoon
we haven't paid enough in our taxes and
that's why we're in the mess we're in
and this government doesn't seem
particularly keen on putting taxes up um
let's now get a nurse's perspective so
we're going to go from patients to the
other side and we're going to speak to
somebody who works on the front line and
has taken part in the recent strike
action she is Antonio berylson a
specialist nurse within the National
Health Service I'll tell you thank thank
you thank you so much for taking the
time to speak to us here on your say
this afternoon
um you've been listening to some of the
calls we've had and different
experiences vastly different experiences
different ends of the scale some with
who have experienced wonderful care
within the NHS and others who have had
such a traumatic time they've
experienced they've developed PTSD
what's it like as a nurse working in the
NHS at the moment
working as a nurse in the NHS is going
is really really tough we're seeing the
managed decline of the NHS over
successive story and coalition
government
um you know the NHS is one of our
proudest institutions the eyes of the
world are upon the NHS
um and essentially it's being failed we
need to put money into employing the
staff paying the nurses and the doctors
and the physiotherapists
an adequate wage and to ensure that it
carries on looking after the health of
the nation because essentially the NHS
ensures that people are healthy are
working and contribution taxes which in
case then goes to carry on the NHS
services and it really is breaking my
heart as an NHS nurse to see us having
to be on the picket lines because we've
spoken out for decades and as Pat
Collins says patients aren't dying
because nurses are striking nurses are
striking because patients are dying and
enough is enough we're standing here as
the natural Advocates of our patients
and saying something has to change
Antonia more strike actions come in
February and March we're looking at
February the 6th the biggest day of
industrial action in NHS history nurses
going back on strike other workers
joining you on that day and to be frank
the government from what everyone you
know negotiating from your side is
saying the government doesn't seem
interested in negotiating more money
from the NHS what we understand the NHS
budget has already been set until 2024
2025 the government you know take advice
from the pay review body and it seems to
be set in stone
do you feel like this strike action will
have any effect
just to make a note that the independent
pay body is not independent what we need
to have on the independent pay review
body is union members from the RCN from
various other unions we need to have
people on the ground adding to this
decision number one
number two we need to make changes
there's only one solution to this crisis
is to encourage the staff to be retained
and encourage staff in and unless we're
paying an adequate wage we are one of
the world's largest economies yet nurses
University educated nurses are relying
on food banks I hadn't made a difficult
decision whether to heat their homes or
whether to eat it's worked out they're
working a shift a week for free and it's
simply not sustainable it's all about
political choices the government had
plenty of money on the sales track and
tray and dodgy PPE contracts
it's all about political choices yeah
Antonio I just want to put something to
um to you that a call I think it was
from uh it was Vincent from Birmingham
who we spoke to earlier on in the
program and he said look if the
government gives in to nurses he has to
give in to ambulance workers he has to
give in to environment agency workers
rail workers so many people are on
strike at the moment because they feel
that the pay they do for their job isn't
enough the whole country is in the
middle of a cost of living crisis
Vincent's arguments seemed to be look
we're all going through it we're all
having to make sacrifices and
and you know he the the Prime Minister
can't give in to everyone there isn't
enough money
let me just reiterate all about
the question the Integrity of the nurses
of the doctors of the ambulance drivers
you know we were risking our lives and
we were applauded on the doorsteps by
the politicians unless we're going to be
relying on gesture politics and empty
promises it's essential and I'm not
going to play into that role of you know
divide and conquer I'm going to say all
essential workers we all need a pay rise
it is simply appalling that there has
been the greatest transport of wealth
from the rich from the poorest to the
riches essentially we need to ensure
that everyone can maintain a good
quality of life you know children are
living in poverty we've seen the
increase of diseases that are caused by
poor housing this is not the country we
want to be we want to have a fairness
and Equity people deserve to have a fair
wage people deserve to be able to pay
their bills not worry about the shipping
adhesive on and that's what makes our
value as a country surely a healthy
population that's paid adequately and
just to reiterate all also also about
pay restoration because we've had as a
profession over 10 years of pay free and
we are a safety you know a profession
that is ensuring the safety of people's
lives I don't feel that we
um should be questioned on that and so
far as we deserve to have a fair wage
perhaps I could sort of speak to
something that you know Antonio's just
said I mean she's a specialist nurse I'm
not sure if the public realize what that
means specialist nurses are palliative
care nurses they're cancer nurses
they're nurses who are looking after
people at the end of their lives going
into homes looking after children with
special needs I mean they are doing work
that deserves to be paid well and I'm
not saying this in a political sense I'm
saying this in the sense of we
undervalue these people who are so in
important individually to our lives and
I know is a GP if it wasn't for
specialist nurses within the community
we wouldn't be able to look after our
patients the way we do we're all part of
this team and the public is hugely
reliant on specialist nurses you're
right you're right and and what Antonio
is saying about pay restoration if you
look at the data over the last 10 years
they've lost 20 percent of the value of
their wage packets because of the
erosion but the difficulty is of course
six million people are on the
government's payroll one way or another
and a quarter of them are on pay review
body reviews and once you unpick one pay
review buddy you've got to unpick the
rest and that's really why I think the
government are trying to keep the can
down the road with this they're going to
push it down to April in March inflation
it looks like it's coming down in April
the pay review body for the NHS starts
again and they'll push it into September
okay well Antonio thank you so much for
joining us here on Sky News Antonio
baross and their specialist NHS nurse
has been taking part in recent strike
action there is Strike action happening
today thousands of NHS physiotherapists
in England are the latest group of
health workers to go on strike in this
dispute overpay physios and their
support staff at 30 NHS Services one in
seven are currently staging a 24-hour
walkout it's the first time members of
the chartered Society of physiotherapy
have gone on strike let's speak to
Skye's Saba Chowdhury she's at Thomas's
Hospital in central London Sabbath
yeah
good afternoon Sarah Jane as you say
this is the first time that the
chartered Society of physiotherapy its
members uh have uh walked out in its
history so something like 4 200 people
would join these members behind me uh
here that's across 30 different trusts
in England and they're striking today in
their striking on February the 9th as
well and February the 7th I should say
in Wales now one of their charts that
really sort of encapsulates what it is
that they're calling for is well you can
hear it for them you can hear it
yourself
when do we want it
[Applause]
Fair pay is what the members of the
charter Society of physiotherapy are
calling for they're saying that they
simply cannot afford to do their jobs
anymore that there isn't enough staff
and that the retention levels of
employees in hospitals is significantly
uh low and that at a payoffer needs to
be attractive in order to retain uh
people in the hospitals they're also
saying that they are as I mentioned
struggling uh with the cost of living
crisis that is impacting so many of us
in the country and they're positioned
here rather poignantly I would say right
in between the houses of Parliament
right outside St Thomas's Hospital
calling on Rishi sunac the Prime
Minister I'm sure you can hear asking
him where their taxes go
their demand to government is loud and
clear
stop striking okay Sabbath thank you NHS
workers outcome rain or shine on those
picket lines uh coming up in a on NHS
crisis you'll say we're going to be
taking your calls on social care you can
get in touch with us this afternoon 0208
167 double two double O is a number to
call
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
welcome back you're watching NHS crisis
you'll say all afternoon we're taking
your calls and giving you the chance to
share your views on the state of the
National Health Service don't forget the
number to call if you want to have your
say on the program this afternoon 0208
167 double two double O right let's get
straight back to the calls we're going
to talk in this section about social
care and joining us on the line is
Stuart whose son had to wait eight
ambulance eight hours for an ambulance
and ended up going to hospital in a
police van Stuart tell me more about
your son and his experience
let me tell you the story thanks very
much for me to give me the opportunity
to talk this afternoon we have some with
complex special needs uh we live in a
rural area Okay the the he has autism
and a diagnosis for autism he also has a
diagnosis for a thing called Prada
Willy's syndrome now Prada Willy's
syndrome is a chromosomal condition and
that condition basically means that the
person who has it uh eats almost
constantly or has the desire to eat
almost constantly
and we have to therefore keep an eye on
his diet
um we have also have learning
difficulties and
late in teenage and early 20s where he
is now you can also find himself in a
situation where he becomes highly
anxious over things and that can
actually sort of bleed over into into
psychosis
um something happened at the college she
goes to something very small in in early
September
this led to a massive anxiety attack on
his part uh his mental health
disintegrated really over a period of 24
hours it's made an attempt on his own
life
um we called an ambulance we called the
police
uh because we were worried about his
safety and also ours because he's 19
years old and he's a big lad
um we waited I suppose for about 10
minutes for the police in about half an
hour for the ambulance services
the ambulance service were great the
police were great unfortunately when
they spoke to the mental health support
people all they could offer was a
diazepam tablet and see what happens
overnight
we waited overnight
um a night wasn't very long he only
slept for a couple of hours he took ages
to get the diazepam tablet into him
um the following day he was really no
better
um we rang the mental health support
line they suggested a particular service
in our area called the autism intensive
support team we rang the numbers for
them the rumbles rang dead the support
team as such at this moment in time does
not exist or certainly didn't at the
time that we we tried to access that
service
we found ourselves in a situation where
he wasn't improving at all during the
course of the day and we found ourselves
having to ring ambulance and ring the
police again
the police arrive very quickly the
ambulance we were told was going to take
about eight hours to arrive
police looked at him looked at us looked
at the situation and said right the only
way we're going to sort this is to get
him into a e in the local hospital she's
not general hospital she's 25 miles away
and so you have a situation where you
had a young man of 19 with learning
difficulties and his dad being taken to
hospital in a police van we were there
for well we got to to the local hospital
we were quite quickly triaged thankfully
he was put into a cubicle we had two
police officers with him who were there
just to look after his welfare we were
told then myself and my wife as parents
were then told to go home because we
were exhausted and he would be assessed
with his mental health and that we would
you know we would be told what the
situation was as soon as they knew
we got home which is a 25 mile an hour
journey and we were more or less told
that we needed to come back in again
because the police were wanted on and
further duties which is understandable
during the time he'd been in hospital in
the cubicle he had become agitated and
somewhat aggressive and the police felt
for their own safety they had to
handcuff him
he was then sedated uh he was sedated
then for about
four days and then was brought home
three days after green brought home they
had what they call the blue light
meeting where about eight different
people over Microsoft teams spent some
time in principle at least
exploring what to do with him we find
ourselves in a situation where
pretty well all the people involved in
the
um meeting really didn't quite know what
to do and we're all almost making
excuses not to help him it was the most
ridiculous situation I've ever known
they got someone in from outside uh a
doctor from another service a
psychiatrist to come and see him that
person wasn't even in the meeting
as things currently stand our son is in
reasonable but not brilliant
psychological Nick
but we have no services for us um if
this happens again then we go back into
the same Merry-Go-Round or we get or we
may well get is diazepam tablet a little
bit of advice and then we have to wait
until they explode to do a situation
where we have to go back into a e
the services are simply not out there
for him and it is an absolute crying
shame
oh Stuart
well first of all I'm so sorry that that
support isn't there for you your wife
and your son I mean
social care is what's needed instead
you're using ambulances going to a e and
the police and sadly it's a story we
hear all too often and because that care
and support isn't there for you um
Stuart stay on the line I'm just going
to bring in um will uh will is in
Chesterfield and has a son with
disabilities
um has an advanced care plan however has
had an experience in a e of a 24-hour
stay
um well talk to me about why you're a e
for 24 hours
yes so my son um
um had respiratory problems and
um
he was taken to the Local District
Hospital in an ambulance but he does
have the advanced care plan and requires
um hdu level care when he's poorly this
plan was written by the NHS and it
explains all of this
um but when the ambulance took us to the
Local District Hospital
um they had real problems trying to
locate a a suitable bed space for him so
we ended up spending 24 hours waiting in
a side room in the a e
we were essentially fending for
ourselves
and eventually they decided to admit
into a general Ward within the local
hospital which wasn't suitable for a
child like him and if I could just
explain that the ward couldn't feed him
because it didn't support his specialist
diet
it couldn't escalate respiratory support
and he was in a real mess
and it couldn't even use his own
ventilator that we'd taken from home due
to a lack of trained staff or so they
told us
um in fact they did tell us that he was
unlikely to even survive the admission
so he was sort of helplessly sat in a
district hospital he should have been in
a hdu setting
um and we eventually spent nine weeks
there
but I was doing most of the Care myself
I couldn't leave the hospital because I
was the other one who could feed him and
the whole experience was absolutely
awful
we're most concerned that it might
repeat again in the future because
um he did have an advanced care app
which was completely disregarded on this
occasion
well how's your son doing now
Mission so that's um obviously excellent
but he's uh he's doing a lot better now
yeah
um largely Testament to to you his dad
by the sounds of it uh stepping in and
filling in the gaps not that you should
ever be put in that position
um but such is the the state of the NHS
that we're hearing about and let's just
uh listen to a voice message now that
was left on this topic earlier and this
is from Carlo uh Carlos from Hitchin in
Hertfordshire color has suspected
Parkinson's and was taken to hospital
after falling twice
I spent a spend a night in IIT on a
trolley
because I'm Pleasant I didn't know what
was wrong with me I I I I had a
neurological condition I couldn't get it
tested in the hospital but when I just
shows me I had a bowel disorder I had on
my leg which was hanging off by now
very painful with with hip and knee
problems I came home and I was on social
care but the social care was shut they
offered me 28 pounds now for six four
months to wash my dishes my my parents
died in the pandemic
and we were still sorting out the
probate because of the probate I was
disqualified from social care unless I
was prepared to play she wasn't
preferred to do
in principle and also
financial reasons but mainly in
principle I'm living alone and coping
with my my medication
which is run out twice I just just
trying to Stave off the advancing
squalor of living alone when you're sick
I went to see about a league about 15
months ago and I've had it scan twice
and they've said you need an operation
but the operations uh it's an active
surgery I'm on the waiting list I don't
know I'm one of the 7.2 million on the
waiting list currency of Mr Johnson and
the lack of planning about post-pandemic
situation
I'll call from Hertfordshire there and
telling us his story thank you Carlo
poor man is deeply troubled isn't he
with multiple needs
which is clearly in the baileywick of
social care social services but you know
we keep repeating the same argument
there are 160 000 vacancies across the
care services
um mainly because they don't pay enough
and and people go and go and work
elsewhere and earn a lot more the the
social care is such an important part of
the delivery of Health Services the
health services can't do what they need
to do well the rest of it doesn't seem
to be able to work properly yeah it gets
completely clogged up if you can't move
people through the system and this this
poor man whoever he is I mean it's clear
he's going to end up as an admission
yeah or he's going to end up you know
with some drama at home that it doesn't
get sorted out I mean we talked earlier
about a failure demand the demand that's
created by failure you listen to that
that's going to cost the fortune to sort
out that's going to be an ambulance a e
you know bad times 300 pounds INE at
least 500 pounds bad 300 pounds a night
and you can just check it all up you
know for what really
small change for getting it sorted out
with social care and with the two
parents who we heard talking about their
kids both in sort of quite different
situations
um we heard about sort of great ideas in
practice somebody had an advanced care
plan somebody had a Microsoft teams
meeting all great ideas in practice and
these Flagship ideas which come across
me in general practice as well the
reality is if you don't have the
Personnel to take the responsibility or
to activate these things it's all very
well having having an advanced care plan
but if you end up in a hospital where
they can't work your ventilator let's
bring in um Professor Vic Rayner CEO of
the national care forum
um Professor Rayner you'll have been
listening to the those callers and to
Roy and Dr Ellie in the studio here
social care is not in a good state
no I
know I think that
mentioned there and in terms of the
level of vacancies that are there in
terms of the patterns and conditions
that are are there I thought from the
the last caller who called through and
talked about
um the impact of having to pay for their
own care so we were also in a situation
where a large-scale government reform
had been promised and committed to by uh
by the Prime Minister and and by the
conservative government and that has
been delayed as well so you know it's a
it's a really really difficult situation
and I agree
um you know that there are all sorts of
challenges for people who are currently
in hospital or being admitted to
hospital about getting access to social
care I think we're not talking enough
about the need for people to have that
social Care at a much earlier stage to
prevent them ever having to get to that
acute stage uh to enable them to have
the support
um whether that's about home adaptations
whether that's about regular kind of
Engagement from social Care staff to
mean that they don't have to fall into
crisis in order to access help it's a
really frustrating it's a terrible
situation to be in as an individual and
if you are trying to make sensible
strategic decisions about what needs
there are in your community if all you
could do is tackle people once they're
at the point of Crisis uh you know we're
just going to be on a constant
Merry-Go-Round of people uh you know
feeling failed and rightly so feeling
failed by both uh Health and Care it's
hugely frustrating
we're seeing now uh the the government
has given the NHS uh two tranches of
money 250 million to buy places in Care
Homes to move 13 000 people out of
Hospital who don't need to be there the
emergency measures that exactly the
Prime Minister and that came out of that
weekend meeting at number 10 which is
fine but first of all you still have to
do an assessment you still have to move
13 000 people when you do that another
13 000 are going to come in and fill the
beds up and more importantly and this is
the the essential point I think Vic
touched on is that if someone's in a
care home and they're expecting to go
home they still need a care package to
get them home so all we've done is push
the problem out and and hope that it
will resolve itself and it won't because
you still have to have that interface
between domiciliary care and Residential
Care yep
I'm going to say I think
the arms welcomes money when it comes
along in that so short term I mean if
you want to try to change the dial on on
this we should be having this
conversation now about March 2024 or not
saying we've got 200 million now you've
got to spend it in the next eight weeks
and then it and then you fall off a kind
of Cliff Edge because there's no further
money available so I think I I think
it's it's just you know I mean I
slightly sort of challenged some of that
kind you know there there are some
fantastic provision within care where
Rehabilitation can go on so for some
people it will be the case that they can
go into a care setting and within a
fixed period of time they can return
home but not everybody's the same uh
lots of people will continue to need
care beyond that and many people will
continue to need to stay within a care
setting because they've actually got to
such a crisis point before they went
into hospital that their ability to
remain remain and living independently
was compromised before they ever entered
Hospital and there's a lot of work that
needs to be done to to support them to
build back up so okay you need to have
all that wrap around assessment as Roy
says but also access to occupational
therapists physiotherapists and a much
wider community support and when we've
dealt with that 13 000 Vic we've got
another 13 000 that have come into those
beds and you're absolutely we've got
half a million people who local
authorities can't even get out to assess
so we don't even know what their needs
are we don't even know where they sort
of sit on that list and yet you know I I
think
that uh
not all of all social care pieces is not
they're not all down to 13 000 people
are not being delayed by social care
alone let you know let's be really real
and realistic about that I mean the the
figures that were given out uh
pre-Christmas about the sort of change
in terms of the number of people who are
being delayed is moving from sort of ten
thousand that are regularly delayed and
up to 13 000. so let's be really honest
about where the kind of delays sit in
the system and you know there are a
whole bunch of reasons why but for
nobody I mean I don't think anybody
would sit around the table and say it's
a good place for somebody to stay in
hospital longer than they need to all
right Professor Reyna CEO of the
national care forum we really appreciate
your time here on the program this
afternoon let's bring in Christine
Christine is from Shropshire and uh is a
former NHS employee in a social care
role um Christine talk to me about your
experience and and your overall View and
assessment of social care in this
country at the moment okay and well
that's part of the problem is this is a
legacy issue that goes back to the split
between Health and Social care I am
under a previous coalition government in
2012. it's a legacy program a problem
and it hasn't addressed the issue until
we address the issue of social care none
of the rest of the things are going to
follow I am I totally agree with the
previous guest speaker we have to get
that right and she also mentioned about
trying to stop people getting to the
crisis situation that was
um my role
um until last year as a community and
care coordinator within a GPS practice
the whole idea was to try and keep
people independent in their own home and
put in packages of care whatever it was
that was needed to support them so they
didn't get into that situation where
they needed to be in hospital and the
trouble was laterally before I left last
year was it was very difficult to try
and get these social care packages put
in place and but there was a whole host
of other things just as the person was
talking about AIDS and adaptions for
people to enable them to remain in their
own in their own home arrange bus passes
heating for their homes
Etc and so there was a whole host of
things that as a care coordinator we
would try and do for people
unfortunately since I've left having
been told there was no funding for my
role going forward the patients at my
practice have had no one to look after
them now because nobody was employed to
take my place which I find is a great
shame because we we helped to ensure
that GPS appointments were freed up for
clinical need and we managed the social
need Christine thank you thank you for
your call I just want to um squeeze in
Brian who's waiting patiently Bryant's
in Cheshire what do you want to say
Brian
hiya I I my story is about my mum last
year and she collapsed at home and she
had a three-hour wait for the ambulance
and then she went into hospital for um
for two to three days
and she still wasn't eaten after the
three days but then she was sent out and
um I pulled up to the hospital taking my
dad who's 93 to see her and then we got
a call and she was just completely
hysterical she'd been taken to um to a
care home and it hadn't been
communicated to her properly and she
thought she'd been put in a hospice and
she would never be getting out and then
going home but she's never she's never
been like that before so she's not the
kind of person that would get
aesthetical it was it was horrible to
see you know
um but then when we went to the care
home to to see it we went from the
hospital to the care home we couldn't
get in because of covered you know they
were sort of you couldn't get to see
them for so many days listen I'm sorry
to interrupt your story we have got to
take a break which is really unfortunate
but can you stay on the line and we'll
talk to you after that yeah no problem
at all yeah thank you Brian we'll see
you in a second thank you help
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to NHS crisis your say I'm
Sarah J me and we are in the middle of a
special program for you here this
afternoon on Sky News we want your views
about the state of Our National Health
Service
Hospital waiting times are the longest
in history thousands of surgeries have
been canceled as the Health Service
struggles to cope
ambulance response times are the slowest
on record and crews are spending entire
shifts parked outside hospitals waiting
to offload patients
a poll suggests a third of people are
unable to book a GP appointment and the
111 phone service is facing
unprecedented demand
with the NHS on its knees industrial
action is spreading in a deepening
dispute with the government do you
support the Striking workers or
completely disagree with their action
and if you've got a positive story to
share we'd like to hear it whether you
work in the NHS or you want to talk
about the treatment you've received we'd
like to hear from you on the program
to have your say call
0208-167-2200 and you could be speaking
to us here on the show this afternoon
[Music]
this is NHS crisis you'll see here on
Sky News today we are launching a
special project a year-long project with
analysis from two leading thinking tanks
to try and find solutions to the crisis
gripping the National Health Service
well this afternoon we are taking your
calls and giving you the chance to share
your views about the National Health
Service before we get back into those
calls and just a reminder of who's in
the studio alongside me we have Roy
Lilly and health policy analyst and
former Vice chairman of West Surrey and
North East Hampshire health authority
and Dr Ellie Cannon GP and author just a
reminder of that number to call if you
want to have your say on Sky News this
afternoon 0208 1672200
before the break we were speaking to
Brian uh he was talking to us about the
treatment his mother received during the
pandemic uh Brian apologies for cutting
you off you understand how it works here
on TV we have to go to those uh breaks
um but please pick up from where you
left off before the break
yeah so so she we got the call from mum
she's the important to the care home so
we dashed from the hospital over to the
care home we couldn't get in because of
the um the things that were happening to
to keep people safe from covert but we
were able to talk through a to her
through a window and calm her down
um but she she really had to go to get
to eat again until she could walk
upstairs because she lived in a house
that was upstairs with no downstairs
bathroom or bedroom so when I spoke to
the care home I said well you know can
you she needs this physiology so but we
don't have any physio capability no
people no equipment and this happens
time and time again we get people sent
out uh and we haven't got the equipment
for them and I rang in the hospital and
I spoke to the physio that had worked
with mum before she was sent out and she
convinced me that she had a proper plan
for mum and everything and I said well
how can she go out to somewhere where
the car be put in place and she said she
didn't she didn't know what was
happening with her and she would pass it
on to her manager
um but um after she still had no
appetite got for days and then she had
severe constipation and in the end I
asked her home to get a GP to speak to
her because she wasn't getting any
better after a week they couldn't even
get a telephone appointment at the care
home and I managed to get Mom's own GP
and he sent us some constipation
medication through but however that
evening the care home center backed away
e again and she was told she'd get a CT
scan to understand the root cause of the
problem but after two to three days she
was sent back to the care home without
any scan and I rang them and they said
she would be called back in for an
urgent CT scan within a week
after a couple of weeks I have no call I
rang the CT department and they told me
it's been marked as routine instead of
agent their error but you would need to
go back onto the list again
um before she could get this scan
before the appointment even came through
she became ill again and she was
collapsing and the care home center back
to a e and this was the last time then
she got this after a few days she got
the CT scan and was told that she had
bowel cancer with a large tumor
um when she was asked if they could when
she asked if they could remove it the
doctor the doctor said the consultant
would not um operate because it was
risky and they were measured on the
success of their operations so I I spoke
to the doctor and asked to see it to
speak to the consultant and he said no
but he would speak to the consultant
because he thought mum was very sharp
mentally and and he wanted to go around
that loop again because of this change
the doctor said it was actually the
consultant's choice not the families as
it had been the family's Choice uh in
the past a couple of years previously
and then after a couple of days in the
hospital mum got covered and she was
putting her own room and we would visit
and we had to wear visors gowns and Mum
and Dad couldn't communicate because of
the visors and they couldn't really hear
each other because of the visors
um because they were both there
reasonably deaf and part way through a
nurse walked in with no equipment to see
him on and she just made a joke and said
you know oh I keep forgetting they're
coming in without this equipment and she
was joking and then she was you know
doing something for mum and she was off
to other Wards then where people didn't
have covered and I just thought you know
this is this is awful this is how mum's
got covered you know it was it and that
and then she she passed just at the end
of the 11 day cycle when she she the
covert had gone and she was able to take
the equipment off she uh she was called
she was treated by palliative care and
they gave her
um something to put her straight to
sleep and she never recovered never
spoke to us again
after that and she died on that last day
of needing to you know get rid of the
equipment she actually passed away that
night so um it was a pretty Torrid
experience to be honest with you and I
appreciate the chance to uh to speak to
you about it because it is quite
therapeutic telling someone about it you
know yeah Brian it's important to talk
about it and we're so sorry for what you
had to go through
um
be interested to hear your thoughts on
what could have helped your mum in terms
of you know we're in the middle of
strike Action Now nurses going on strike
for the you know for the first time in
100 Years of you know biggest NHS strike
action coming up on February the 6th
what do you think could be done to help
the NHS and those who access it for
treatment
the the big thing for my mom was a
couple of years ago she had something
similar she'd gone in for two and a half
weeks to the hospital and she got they
got after a week they got it eaten again
and they got all the physio equipment
she was up and down the stairs and then
she was she she went back home and she
meant we managed to get another two
years with her after that this time it
was very clear they just didn't have the
time they didn't have the beds that you
know they just wanted her out as fast as
possible uh for whatever those reasons
are but the thing was put her into the
care home and they haven't got the
equipment that she went out with a
physio plan for somewhere that she
couldn't get that treatment it it sounds
like you know a couple of years ago when
people began Center Care Homes at covert
it's almost like we need to get them out
and we'll do whatever we need so I think
they should I think it I think the
nurses and and they should be paid
market rate I think you know I'm
assuming a few years ago the wear paid
market rate and then with all the um the
issues with uh you know in inflation and
stuff like that cuts it's obviously gone
below market rate but if someone said
just given the nurses 10 is going to
make a difference I I don't think it
will it will it will reduce I'm sure
people leaving but it needs an
end-to-end review you know these people
stuck in ambulances you know one of the
times mum was was sent back from the
care home she was overnight before she
got back into any kind of award she was
in an ambulance she was in corridors she
was 91 you know with you know late
stages of bowel cancer unbeknownst to us
it's just not human that people get
treated in that way so I think it needs
to be looked at end to end and of course
paying people market rate is a part of
that but it's nothing like the full
solution and to fix this because it does
feel it's broken to me and there are
some wonderful people in there my wife
had a brain hemorrhage level four bleed
a couple of years ago and she was
treated magnificently and she's with us
now you know and the treatment's been
fantastic so it's not just all bad my
experience but I do want to see it fixed
because I don't want to see the people's
Mom and Dad going through this kind of
problem yeah we okay that Brian thank
you so much for coming on to talk to us
here at Sky News and there's pressure on
beds yeah that all of that story
results from the pressure that there is
to discharge people to free up beds but
also it's what you said earlier which is
it's that interface it's those cracks in
the pavement between the two very
different Services Brian's mum had a
care plan for discharge she had a
physiotherapy care plan and that was an
activated when she was in the community
yeah okay and Brian as I said thank you
so much for coming on and telling us
your mum's story and also your wives as
well good to know that she's doing well
we really appreciate it here on Sky News
and if you want to have your say here on
the program 0208
1672200 we're going to discuss GPS now
literally knows a thing or two about a
GP practice and he figures out this
afternoon show the number of permanent
GPS in England has fallen year on year
for the seventh month in a row let's go
straight to a caller I know you've got
plenty to say about this um Dr rally but
I first call it is Chris and Chris is
from East riding in Yorkshire
um and has never had an issue with
getting a GP appointment in his area
people watching this afternoon Chris
will go lucky you talk to me about your
GP surgery and the level of access you
get
oh yeah good afternoon
um yeah I mean I I started really with
with the NHS imagery period probably
about 2016 when I got diagnosed with
cancer that's another story but more
recently
um
and and since then to be honest as a
family we never have a problem with
obtaining a GP appointment within a
relatively short
um time frame there's various options
you can bring in the morning you might
get put on hold for a little bit but um
you always get through if not an
appointment that day which certainly
within a couple of days have emergency
slots at the end
and we can also book online so that
there are additional appointments where
we can register book online and that's
it usually that's actually quite quite a
bit quicker than telephone call and
um my personal experience in terms of
what happened recently was
um I presented with a a back problem
um which I had since November sometime
I've seen within um a day of calling
um but I'd had a couple of symptoms that
when I presented those to the to the
doctor uh raised raised his eyebrows to
be fair he he pushed a button in terms
of he suspected I may have had it a
couple of tias which are mini strokes as
well in the medical world and from there
on in
um the treatment was fantastic the
following day
contacted by a consultant from the
stroke Clinic that afternoon I was into
the local Hospital MRI
um cathode artery scans ECGs Bloods Etc
I got the results with the following
conversation the following day by the
same consultant it also jacked up a CT
scan to pay after which all came back
fines in a nutshell I'd uh I've made the
call
been been seen and and some posted
through to the stroke clinic and it was
all done and understood successfully
thankfully within within four days the
hospital I've got to say was was top
draw and the whole world infirmary was
it was fantastic and certainly an IQ and
ambulances
clean
happy and helpful staff and the
experience was was fantastic as it has
been as has been through the last sort
of um six to seven years I don't you
know it's quite subjective whether or
not but it's some sort of postcode
lottery or what I'm not I'm not sure but
certainly in this part of the world and
my my local GP service in particular
no complaints
um because we often do hear about people
that cannot get a GP appointment can't
even get through on the phone sit there
waiting for 45 minutes just to speak to
you know the receptionist uh or a
doctor's assistant who said there aren't
any appointments today call back
tomorrow at eight o'clock so it's really
good to have a positive story to kick us
off with I'm going to bring in uzma from
Luton isma's been a GP for six years as
well what do you want to say to us here
today on Sky News and I just wanted to
say that GPS are generally very
hard-working and resilient people and
they are feeling I would say overwhelmed
frustrated with the situation because
they like yourself like your callers are
patients as well and we have problems
getting through to our GP
um and it's a problem of supply and
demand and they've just simply Aren't
Enough GPS we need more of them we've
been promised more of them it just isn't
coming true
yeah Dr Eddie I'm sure you'll Echo that
it's supply and demand it's not the GPS
don't want to see you but there are only
so many appointments to go around it's
really frustrating for you as it is for
patients absolutely and we only went
into medicine as somebody said earlier
you know to help people and to look
after people when I was applying for GP
jobs in
2007-2008. I had to
um I actually wrote on my CV his
anecdote who actually wrote on my CV
that I had two children I wasn't
planning to have anymore and the reason
I wrote that is because I know when they
employ you they're not allowed to ask if
you want maternity leave or you're going
to have any more kids and I wanted to be
employable because it was very very
difficult to get a GP job 15 years ago
now and as I said I work in a very good
practice we advertise for a GP post and
we cannot find GPS well we have lost a
lot of GPS because of pension crises
because of burnout we've hemorrhaged at
one end of the career and at the other
end of the career you have huge numbers
of Junior doctors who opt out of the NHS
who go half NHS half private who move
abroad we are just not attracting GP so
we're about five or six thousand GP
short Roy is going to give us figures
yes I mean I'll give you some numbers
here the GPS do 30 million appointments
a month
30 million a month 40 of which are on
the same day yeah the rest are either
video or don't require a same day and
can be done you know another time in the
week we've lost uh 700 uh 600 uh we've
had a net loss of 600 GPS since 2021 we
lost 600 and the government keeps saying
we've got more GPS in the service than
ever before we have but their GPS in
training right we've so we our net gain
since 2019 is just over 700 GPS there
are only 28 000 GPS in the country under
30 000. that's why you can't get an
appointment let's bring in Fiona from
Salisbury um Fiona from Salisbury thinks
that you know GPS are overworked and you
know Dr Ellie's nodding her head um in
that and Fiona in that you think that
they're making mistakes talk to me about
your experience
hi there um yes so I mean it was quite
hard to pick an experience and I think
that's probably relevant to most people
that are phoned in that there's more
than one um experience but most recently
and most significant I suppose I
presented a CP with uh confusion
um
loss of function to my legs and
hallucinations and the GP focused
immediately and on the hallucinations
because I I have bipolar disorder and
put me on a very high dose of
antipsychotics
um I did ask at the appointment to have
a urine test because I believed myself
to have a urine infection that wasn't
done
um a month later I presented again to my
GP where a nurse received a urine sample
from me and ran it she told me that she
didn't think I had a urine infection
despite the fact that I did and then I
heard back from her and she said she'd
done her dipstick and that I had no
urine infection I then went on to almost
completely use lose use of my legs
sporadically I became almost completely
incontinent at night I was hallucinating
on the school run when I was picking up
my child taking her into school and I
presented back at the GP being carried
in by my husband and after a very
invasive test which I'm sure the GPS
that are listening will know is
um I was I was the doctor I'm very well
turned around and said let's see if that
urine infection has cleared up and we we
did swear but I won't swear here said
what urine infection and she said that
my test result so they'd sent my sample
off to the lab a month previous and my
test result had come back as positive
thing
at that point for I estimate around
three months and it's not even that they
didn't diagnose it properly they just
didn't bother to phone me and tell me
that that diagnosis had had been made I
put in a pretty extensive report to the
GP surgery whose response was to Double
Down tell me that I was cracking for
drugs and remove me from the practice
now I at this point was under the care
of the mental health Team I was under
the care of the physiotherapy team I
also have chronic fatigue syndrome I
know exactly what is wrong with me so I
wished to utilize 111 in order to
receive my repeat prescriptions which I
had some specialist doctors without
actually enrolling at a GP surgery
because I feel that that should be
something that is optional I believe GPS
in the most part are doing the job of a
slow loading App very badly they are
diagnosticians I've been to a GP they
picked up a book and started rifling
through it we live in the 21st century
that actually don't need a person who
may or may not
it's over training on your particular
condition to rifle for a book and tell
us what we need we should be able to
have an application that we can put
those details into and let's face it you
could put those details into an
application and it could take 45 minutes
okay well and it would still be more
functional than the majority of GP
practices but you've had an awful
experience I'm just going to give Dr
Elliot a right to reply there about GPS
because I mean this is a gp's worst fear
right getting a diagnosis wrong that
leads to such serious consequences for a
patient and yes GPS are overworked
and mistakes are made GPS are human
beings but in the main just how much is
the state of the NHS affecting your
ability to do your job that sounds like
a particularly horrific case from Fiona
yeah I'm really sorry to hear that Fiona
I mean obviously we have situations
where if people are overworked when any
of us are overworked on anybody's burnt
out when you've got a thousand different
things being said to you all at once and
you're thinking about all different
things because you don't have enough
staff on the ground mistakes are going
to happen it would happen if you were
reading the news it would happen if you
were flying a plane it would happen to
anybody mistakes and unfortunately we
end up with these situations Fiona's
story I'm sorry to say is familiar to me
because a urine sample you know we get
thousands of urine samples into
practices every day a urine sample
result can easily out of the 50 you
might get into one GP surgery one might
get missed somebody might forget to
might make that phone call or forget to
dock document that they need to be found
and this is going to happen with with
the lack of staff and also I should say
as well that within GP surgeries we've
got a lot of other staff not just GPS we
have fantastic nurses Healthcare
assistants Pharmacists and our admin
staff who really are the backbone and
they are also leaving the NHS in droves
because they can go and work in retail
where there's far less stress for more
money for patients to keep the pressure
up on their GP surgery because I know
we've had callers on this special
program today and you've said follow up
follow up
if like Fiona Fiona was in no doubt in
her mind what was wrong with her and you
know we've had again callers and people
get in touch with this here at Sky News
and Becky Johnson our correspondent was
with the West Midlands ambulance seeing
him an elderly man who'd follow over and
did his wife didn't call the ambulance
because she didn't want to bother them
because the NHS is in crisis
elderly people they just feel the
message
but if you get something like a urine
sample I mean that that's in that's
that's simply I mean it's not acceptable
but it's simple result you just use a
barcode system so it so it gets flagged
up automatically and nothing gets
forgotten just an investment yeah that's
required in the system and that's what
we haven't had for for too long let's
bring in Clyde from Essex um Clive
couldn't get a GP appointment and it
resulted in him going to A and E Clive
talk to us oh hello yeah it was just
after Christmas I had a very nasty
infection in my hand which was spread
into my arm it actually turned out to be
a strap eye infection it was diagnosed
in hospital it was worsening daily I
tried to get a GP appointment and bear
in mind I hadn't bothered my doctor for
three years but I couldn't get through
at first I tried try tried then
eventually I got through and was told
phone back tomorrow we've got no more
appointments I got in touch with 111
service for advice I did speak to a
doctor on the phone who prescribed me
antibiotics but by this stage this
situation was getting so bad that the
arm was going black and blistered I was
in terrible pain that my wife phoned for
an ambulance at 4am in the morning to be
told unless I stopped breathing the
weight was 32 hours
eventually my neighbor took me by car to
a e where I was rushed through and
admitted I was transferred by ambulance
to another hospital where I went
straight into theater I had three
operations constant antibiotics was very
very ill after two weeks I was better I
was discharged I was the best care in
the world a surgeon told me I lucky not
to lose my arm or even my life so I'm so
grateful to the hospital and the NHS
saving me but I was initially
disappointed how bad the primary care
was I don't blame anyone who works in
the doctors the 111 service the
ambulance service they have to work
under these Financial constraints but I
might not be here now or I might only
have one arm it came down to that in in
the end and my doctor did phone to
apologize once I was home and she said
that um that that she is just at the end
of her tether she feels like quitting
um and and you know it's such a sad
situation I don't want to see that
either but the fact is if we'd caught
this earlier
um I might not have had to have gone
through that experience and and may not
have have had to have got so ill but I
just couldn't get anyone from primary
care to help me it it just had it it
wasn't there when I needed it I'm afraid
that's basically it I listened to that
hearing that from Clive and I'm hearing
about him a few patients have mentioned
about phoning at eight o'clock in the
morning so we were sort of more
digitalized because of the pandemic and
more Tech was put into general practice
and in in the practice where one of my
children is registered you don't have to
phone up you can fill out a sort of 200
word form online at any time of day and
then you go on to the triage list so you
don't have to fight with the phones in
the practice where I work you can do the
same thing called an e-consultation all
practices this is what we when we talk
about these sort of like patchiness of
the NHS all practice should offer that
nobody in the country should be fighting
with the phones we should be able to do
this should be a uniform system across
because it works because it works and
it's better for doctors because we can
triage we can read in your own words in
that sort of situation what's going on
and it's far better for patients because
some GP surgeries now say send us
photographs and they send you a link
absolutely
finally woken up to the fact there is
technology it's worth saying something
as well about the ambulance it just
keeps coming up the in 2016 the
ambulance service first started
categorizing calls and they did it
because they didn't have enough
ambulances and the demand was starting
to get overwhelming so they got category
one two three and four one is like
you're bleeding to death or you stop
breathing a category two and this is the
thing that that people find so difficult
category two includes you Granny lying
on the kitchen floor with a broken hip
an epileptic fit a seizure a heart
attack so all of these categories that
where it didn't really matter then
because the gap between a category one
response and a category 2 response was
quite small but it just it did give the
ambulance to get off the back foot and
sort itself out now of course that Gap
has widened and because the ambulance
services are so busy and so delayed in
Handover we're only getting to the
category one laws and the category 2
cores are really causing people huge
problems okay let's bring in uh Satya
who is in Wolverhampton a GP for 30
years and has retired as Satya and
you've never experienced the NHS uh as
bad as this
well good afternoon to everybody good
afternoon and I must say that although a
lot of conversation has gone on about
access
one of the hard takes is about this
fragmentation of services
let me just qualify what I'm in my
fragmentation
I have been a GP for 31 years as you
said and I retired 10 years ago but now
in last 10 years I've seen I could if I
need it I could go to 111 or to
emergency or I could call out of the
hours or I could call GP services within
the accident and emergency department I
don't know where to go to and that's a
GP who has been working for 31 years
I pity those people who have to make
these choices because sometimes they end
up in the wrong place and then they are
shunted out to another place because now
this is not our choice you go through
and when they go to the other place
let's say gpk they'll say well go to
your own GP
well going to three four three four
places for one problem doesn't seem
right to me because it looks like this
is wastage of valuable resources
it's almost like patients are being
given more choice but that might
necessarily be a good thing when it
comes to Primary Care certainly good
afternoon you're absolutely right this
is the too many front door syndromes
which front door do you go through and
it is confusing for patients it's only
come about because over time demand has
exceeded the ability to to resolve a
problem so we didn't have one one one we
just had 999 and if you needed help you
called 999 the problem is a lot of
people called 999 for things that
weren't really emergencies so we had one
one one put in which which it started
out as being I think a pretty helpful
advice line for people it went through a
bit of a bad period and it's got back on
its feet again now but but if you look
at if you analyze the 111 calls and so
many of them get referred to 999 or get
referred to the GP so video appointment
with a GPA in a lot of cases yes one one
can now book appointments in rgp surgery
so they hold slots and they have got
they don't have to fight with the phones
it doesn't it doesn't limit demand it
spreads demand and diffuses it
throughout the system and that's where a
lot of people find it confusing yeah
okay well we've been hearing a lot about
problems and dissatisfaction with the
NHS this afternoon we have asked the
government to respond and invited the
health secretary to come on here to Sky
News he declined but we have renewed
that request for someone from the
government to come on to the channel
earlier sky and you spoke to Julian
redhead the national Clinical Director
for Urgent and Emergency Care in NHS
England who said that some things are
improving
we're all working very very hard to work
together to try and improve that
discharge situation and making sure that
we can move patients into appropriate
care settings as they recover from their
illnesses which brought them into
hospital and I think it's really
important that we are understanding
there's pressures in all parts of the
system here but the more that we can
work together to achieve that the better
we can we are seeing some progress in
some of the work as we work as we do
this with the local authorities with our
community colleagues to make sure that
we are able to move patients through the
system and we'll continue that work work
ongoing
oh this is NHS crisis your say we'll be
taking more of your calls and discussing
the long-term future of the National
Health Service before we come back after
this break
[Music]
foreign
there's always more to the news than a
headline we want to discover to delve a
little deeper to find out what's really
going on explanation analysis the people
at the heart of every story I'm Neil
Patterson and this is this guy News
Daily podcast Alex Crawford joining us
now from Ukraine their personal
possessions are all scattered around the
place our economics and data editor Ed
cordaway try them extensive at the big
numbers for us things can change
incredibly quickly that's what they have
done so by the end we'll hopefully all
understand what's going on in the world
just that little better available
whatever you get your podcast
foreign
[Music]
thank you
welcome back you're watching NHS crisis
your say all afternoon we've been taking
your calls and giving you the chance to
have your say about our National Health
Service plenty to discuss thank you for
watching at home we have a caller now
who's been compelled to call us this
afternoon after watching from his home
in Hertfordshire it is Sir Rod Stewart
so Rod Stewart good to hear from you
this afternoon thank you so much for
calling in what made you pick up the
phone hi Sarah hi I've been watching the
program all day and uh yesterday I went
for my yearly scan which is private
obviously and I was 20 minutes late and
I phoned in I said I'm terribly sorry
I'll be there was a half an hour late I
phoned him I got in there and they said
I said I'm so sorry I'm so late I said
oh we're not busy at all we've only got
a couple of customers today I won't tell
you where it was but my point being this
is ridiculous you know and I I would
like to pay 10 by 10 or 20 scans I don't
know how we're going to work this out
and I hope some other people will follow
because it seems ridiculous that this
particular scanning Clinic was empty and
there are people dying because they
cannot get scans now listen to me I
don't need the publicity
um uh you know I just want to do some
good things and this I think is a good
thing because if other people follow me
I'd I'd love it that's such a a generous
thing to do thank you for calling us and
somehow we'll work it out because that's
such a great offer and I'm sure you know
callers like Ezra that we spoke to
earlier on on the program here he's been
through prostate cancer I mean that kind
of generosity is literally a lifeline
and you've been through two bouts of
cancer what's your experience been like
within the NHS uh well obviously it
wasn't within the NHS I went privately
because you know I've got a few
Shillings as you know Sarah but um it
was tremendous but I know damn well this
this NHS has to be rebuilt it's been
around since 1947 it's got to be rebuilt
with billions of billions of dollars
that's the only way we're going to go
around it okay
go and tell Eddie I'll play for his scan
and 10 or 20 others however however much
it takes
and and so Rod you know I know you
watched Sky News a lot and you'll be
well aware of all the strike action uh
that's taking place amongst NHS staff
it's continuing into February and March
there's no end in sight and what are
your thoughts on what the government
should be doing about NHS workers who
want decent pay and they want conditions
they want to save the NHS in their words
absolutely they're not asking for a
great deal um I personally have been a
touring for a long time but I think this
government should stand down now and
give the labor party a go at it because
this is heartbreaking for the nurses it
really is heartbreaking in all my years
of living in this country I've never
seen it so bad and anything I can do to
help go on the nurses I'm on your side
and I'm sure you have family members who
have used the NHS as well like you said
there are
um people like yourself lucky enough to
be able to afford private care and
that's something that more and more
people are exploring whether they're
wealthy middle income earners or just
scraping the money together to help
themselves or family members how is it
how important is it that we have a
Health Service a National Health Service
that is free at the point of entry from
the Cradle to the Grave if you like how
important is it that the NHS stays as it
is and isn't privatized or is that
somewhere some way of saving it
privatizing it in part well maybe
they're somewhere down the middle you
know if we're going to privatize it it
could become terribly expensive
um as for my family my immediate family
and all my kids I'm lucky enough to send
them to to a private service but uh I
don't know this is this is a bad time
for us in Great Britain it really is
change the bloody government
okay
you're making your political political
points very clear here on Sky News do
you have to point out obviously that
people do have other views and you know
we have had callers on here saying give
Rishi soon a chance they promise to sort
out
um the National Health Service and other
issues facing the company uh country but
of course you know um the government
have been around for over a decade now
which is the Counterpoint to this
argument just just private sector thing
is interesting because the NHS is buying
more has more contracts with the private
sector now than it did before covid it's
making a huge use of the private sector
but of course the private sector charge
is a premium to to private patients and
they don't get paid as much for doing
work for the NHS as they do for their
private clients and what we see so they
don't there's no great incentive for
them to do it and what we see with
private services and I've experienced
this as well with my own family is
whenever there's they can sort of cream
off the patients who they want to see so
if there is any risk for example in
mental health services or if there is
sort of difficult cases or when things
go really badly wrong actually people
are fed back into the NHS it is
interesting they've got a I think I'm
right in saying they've got about 800
operating theaters and most of them
don't have itus so if anything goes
wrong during an operation they have to
ring 999. right bear with me we do have
to say goodbye to Rod Stewart thank you
so much for calling in just a final
question if I may and you've been
listening to the the program today
members of the public calling in having
their say this afternoon is there a
particular story that's resonated with
you
uh every one of them I must admit I have
the television on the back you know in
the background while I'm working on my
model railroad but uh it it it's it's
just terribly sad I'm so proud to be
British and I can't stand it being in
this way so you're doing a great job you
guys on there keep up a good work and
I'm a big fan of Sarah oh well funny
enough I'm a big fan of yours
take care of you guys my mum's favorite
Maggie May okay
we did wonder how we were going to end
the program on a positive note today
you're delivered um
and the offer of 10 to 20 cats to scans
for people will get in touch off air sir
Rod Stewart and we'll sort that out
thank you so much
as you'll say thank you
you never know who's watching you never
know who's going to happen I'll sit up
straight pay attention yeah well to end
the show we want to discuss the
long-term future of the Health Service
we've left the tricky one till last at
how to fix the problems that the service
currently face let's get another caller
on shall we we will get on Michael who's
in Eastbourne and Michael your thoughts
um come to the workers on strike and you
think a pay rise is part of the solution
I certainly do um I had a triple heart
bypass and the Eastbourne Hospital who
brought me around and then sent me on to
the Royal Sussex Hospital in Brighton
were absolutely amazing the the job they
do they do they show great patience they
come up with all sorts and you know they
have to go on strike why but uh the way
I see it is um did the government not
just give the barristers and that a pay
rise without any argument so why are
they not giving the nurses pay rise in
line with them
they see them at the food bank do you
yeah I mean we should we should point
out that you know the health secretary
Department of Health the government say
that the door is open uh they want
constructive discussions uh with the NHS
workers and they are in the words of the
health secretary listing uh if you
listen to the unions they don't feel uh
that the government is listening um
let's bring in James who is in Liverpool
um and James you're pretty angry about
what's going on and you're angry with
the government for their handling of the
strikes
no yes I think he should get get the pay
rise
if
Denise is I mean
can I just really love what my problem
with my wife
COPD
crystallizing of the heart comes with
both hands bronchiosis on we're offering
Isis area
antidroid problems now we regularly go
to the hospital and the treatment we get
is Superhead
I mean these people are so dedicated
it's unbelievable
and to be treated
by a government is scandalous
and I think the government
should back in and have a general
election
I mean I had to go and see my counselor
yesterday and I only found out the
social care in knowsley since 2010
144 million pounds
I know a lady who struggles up the
stairs
can't get a lift or a walk-in shower
because about that much money taken of
us not only knows the other parts of the
country but all suffering but
this governments
I don't know I'm disgusted I've never
known the Conchita is such a bad State a
man's 75 this year it's disgusting yeah
I can I can I can hear how passionate
you are in your voice and thank you so
much for taking the time to call to call
us as I said you know the government
will say their door is open they are
talking negotiations are ongoing and
they have a plan to to save the Health
Service let's talk now
um to professor John Appleby director of
research and chief Economist of the
Independent Health Think Tank the
nuffield trust and good to talk to you
this afternoon
uh where do we go from here we're
looking at strike action the biggest day
of strike action by the NHS ever coming
up on February the 6th we've talked
about how we've got here where do we go
next
so I'm sure as you've discussed is and
people who've phoned in it's in a bit of
a hole at the moment I mean I don't know
whether you've gone through some of the
numbers but we've got something like 40
of people waiting over 18 weeks when the
target is eight percent no more than
eight percent for elective weights total
waiting list 7.2 million back in January
2020 just before covert it was around
4.4 million about a third of people are
waiting over four hours in a e when the
target is no more than five percent I
could go on ambulance category one
um average response times 11 minutes
when the target is seven minutes
Diagnostics 27 waiting more than six
weeks when no more than one percent
should wait that long so it is what it
says on the title of you know your say
today it's a crisis it is a question
that we we want to throw forward to is
what are the what are the solutions how
do we get out of where we've got to
well the the general consensus uh of
people who've looked at this in terms of
what does the NHS need what sort of
money does it need to provide the sort
of service that we would like reasonable
waiting times covering changes in the
population we've got an aging population
it's also growing as well how much would
we roughly need each year well the
figure that pops out time and time again
is around a four percent real increase
in NHS funds each year
um the thing is that we haven't been
getting that uh or the NHS hasn't been
getting out so over the last decade to
20 20 21 and you have to exclude the
special covered money the average per
year has been about 1.4 so just enough
to cover increases in the population and
changes in numbers of elderly and so on
last year a bigger increase six percent
this year nine percent but the
government plan to reduce those
increases so next year three percent and
in 24 25 about 1.5 now there's a lot of
numbers there but the point is that
um the NHS hasn't been really been
getting the money that most people have
looked at this think it needs to produce
the sort of um Quality Service uh that
we need now uh we're in a different
position now
um strikes aside covid has got a long
tail for the Health Service not just for
People's Health hospitals having to work
differently to cope with covid in terms
of the infection control and so on
that's reduced productivity but the
population still is still growing people
are still knocking on whichever front
door there is to the NHS with problems
and so on
so we'll we're really looking for I
think more money
um probably more than four percent a
year on average for the medium term
we're also looking for new ways of
delivering Services one of the things
that's come out of covid is the use of
remote technology
um I've been looking at outpatients
so there are 120 million outpatient
appointments each year a huge number uh
we used to do about four percent of
those uh remotely by telephone or by
computer and so on that figure has now
gone up to about 20 to 25 percent uh now
that may help improve productivity
but I think productivity alone is not
going to solve the problem where as I
say the the when you look at the
performance of the NHS and where we're
at at the moment it's in in a pretty
deep hole and that's going to take time
and resource to uh to recover
and professor John Appleby thank you for
the moment and as you said there is
investment being put in year on Year by
the government but such is the chasm
that has been left by underfunding
um in previous years it's it's not
enough no you're right I mean the and
John's absolutely right and we we were
talking about this earlier we've had 10
years of Flatline funding the four
percent figure is is the key figure and
if you look at the uh annual average
since uh 1946 through to today it's
about 3.8 around 4.4 so that four
percent figure is is absolutely right
and and the other issues really around
uh growth and what have you sort of
fought into that situation but
fundamentally
and it's absolutely true the government
have been throwing money at the at the
problems now and that's really
firefighting a lot of it's wasted on on
uh agency fees and things like that
which is a real waste of public money it
is not cost effect active and it's the
difference between funding the Health
Service and investing in the Health
Service and we didn't do what Germany
and France and other European countries
did during covid and after covid and
certainly we didn't do it during the 10
years after the world banking crisis we
didn't invest in our Health Care system
and that's why the chickens are coming
home to roost now that's a really good
distinction to make between funding and
investing let's speak to Dillis Dillis
is in North Wales and has extremely
positive experiences with the NHS but is
worried more people are going private
Dillis talk to us
oh hello hello how are you what is it
you want to say here on Sky News good
afternoon what do I want to say goodness
for me
um
one of these stories uh I was coming in
with
um I love the NHS and that has a
wonderful experience of it but it
doesn't seem relevant at the moment
um no Dennis we it's important to
highlight the good in the NHS you know
I've had a good experience in the NHS I
have my daughter
um you know in an NHS paternity Ward
there are good stories out there Dylan I
think it's important to highlight that
because that's why people want to keep
the NHS stories for these good stories
yeah Dennis we need you talk to us all
right I do need I do want to keep the
NHS it's absolutely my hospital I I've
had obviously during covid from 2000 and
uh and it there was the doctors
disappeared
um you you couldn't you couldn't see
them at all and most of the time you
couldn't speak neither so
they just disappeared and then we have
from 2020 we had this massive Gap thing
since since we've sort of resurrected
ourselves after it and everybody can
come out on everything else then I've
just had I've had a lot of the stuff
that I've been
sitting on and waiting all my problems
um I've had them seem to they're all in
a band seeing too and the hospital
system that I go to the hospital I go to
in in wrexham is just amazing so the the
staff and everybody else in the whole
hospital is like it's been
and that's just a look of it so I've had
a
problems have been from cancer process
or processor
which turned out I'm
particularly for the another checkup and
I'm keeping my fingers crossed
um I've had no circulation in my legs so
that that terrible I had cancer I had I
had sorry I had covid
the first time around I had covered then
I had covert again which left me with
long covered
so I've had other problems
just can't fault the NHS and the
hospital and the staff
as far as the investment in hospital in
the NHS I I lived in
[Music]
um
no have we have we had a brain Drive in
England brain brain drain a brain drain
in the UK because there doesn't seem to
be anybody with anything in their head
the government really are they come up
with the most silly ideas
um
that's one I heard was took charge
people for an appointment with the
doctor
well Dylan's not everyone thinks that's
a silly idea because of course you know
as Dr Ellie will I'm sure say that you
know appointments are missed that's
appointments that people desperately
need so some people think charging
people for GP appointments is a good way
to um to ensure those appointments are
kept and uh is run efficiently Dennis
thank you so much Colleen we need we
needed a caller like you we needed a bit
of an uplift and thank you for watching
everyone this afternoon you never know
where people are watching our next
caller is actually in hospital this is
Shirley she is endeavor she's in
hospital right now and has been for the
last 10 days um Shelly how are you
getting on
[Music]
just find out about 20 minutes ago I can
be going home tomorrow so
I'm pleased with that that is very good
and usually and of course you're in
hospital in the midst of all this NHS
crisis uh nurses going on strike physios
on strike today and have you spoken to
any of the the staff about what's going
on do you support them how how's the
morale
yeah I support the staff 100
um they have my full backing they are
not getting what they deserve they are
fantastic
um it doesn't matter what time of day
you ring your bell or
you know you've got a problem like you
could have left the bed or whatever
they've always got a lovely smile on
their face and calm and make you feel at
ease you know and that goes a long way
oh
um Shelly it sounds like you know 10
days in hospital nobody wants 10 days
but it sounds like the care that you've
received there and from the staff has
really made a difference to your stay
because you sound in High Spirits
yeah I mean they saved my life so many
times these last 10 years you know I hit
the criteria with covert like you know
it will be um negative marks because of
my time
um and they cut me through that last
month I was in with heart problems
and they saved my life very serious you
know and I can't vote them you know I
even asked my mp to do a shift with them
so we could see how they work yeah
you've not been you've not been the
first person to suggest that here on the
program this afternoon Shirley we really
wish you well glad that you're getting
out of Hospital don't hang around on the
phone to us I'm sure you want to pack up
and get out of there as soon as possible
Shelly thank you so much for talking to
us Shirley in hospital in Devon there
we've only got a minute left just a
final thought from both of you on where
we go next uh we've got to fix social
care uh that's the the important thing
we have to have a Workforce plan
properly funded and we have to step back
and give the NHS a bit of space and a
bit of time to get back on its feet and
it will deliver
yeah absolutely I mean we need to plan
we've heard so much now today about the
fact that we didn't plan we went into
covid we were already in some crisis so
the crisis just got worse we don't plan
for our Workforce there's no long term
planning we need a government who are
prepared to plan social care and do
these proactive things for first and
plan the workforce for the next 10 to 15
years and something we've heard about
here on the program today is not
splitting Health yeah and social Care
One can't work without the other and the
effects that we're hearing has been
really dramatic the common sense of the
people who phoned in they support the
nurses they understand the burratic
bureaucratic mess and and listen to the
people uh Roy Dr Ellie thank you so much
for joining us here on NHS crisis your
say we have a special debate coming up
for you live from Coventry that's coming
up next Coventry Hospital Sky News
begins a year-long project to find
solutions to this crisis
[Music]
foreign